Tim Ferriss: Hello, ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show.
I'm going to keep my preamble short because
I would like to get into the meat and potatoes
of this conversation that I've been looking
forward to.
My guest today is John Vervaeke on Twitter.
You can find him @Vervaeke_John.
He is a professor of psychology and cognitive
science at the University of Toronto.
He currently teaches courses on thinking and
reasoning with an emphasis on cognitive development,
intelligence, rationality, mindfulness, and
the psychology of wisdom.
Vervaeke is the director of UToronto's Consciousness
and Wisdom Studies Laboratory and its Cognitive
Science program where he teaches Introduction
to Cognitive Science and the Cognitive Science
of Consciousness, emphasizing the 4E model,
which I'm sure we will get into, which contends
that cognition and consciousness are embodied,
embedded, enacted, and extended beyond the
brain.
Vervaeke has taught courses on Buddhism and
cognitive science in the Buddhism, Psychology,
and Mental Health program for 15 years.
He is the author and presenter of the outstanding
— that's what I'm adding — YouTube series
— I highly recommend — Awakening from
the Meaning Crisis and his brand new series,
After Socrates.
You can find all things John Vervaeke at johnvervaeke.com.
That is spelled V-E-R-V-A-E-K-E, johnvervaeke.com.
John, thank you so much for taking the time
today.
John Vervaeke: Great pleasure to be here,
Tim.
Great pleasure, indeed.
Tim Ferriss: Could you please elaborate on
the four ways of knowing?
John Vervaeke: Sure.
The idea about a taxonomy that has to be principled.
And so what it is, is every one of these kinds
of knowing has a particular vehicle, a particular
result, a particular standard, and a particular
kind of memory.
I'm not going through all of these things
to be pedantic.
I'm going through to these to show that this
is a rigorous taxonomy, that this is like,
because you can cut up the world however you
want.
But in the scientific taxonomy, you want it
to be very systematic and rigorous.
The kind of knowing we're most familiar with,
and our culture is very fixated on, is propositional
knowing.
This is knowing that something is the case.
This is knowing that cats are mammals, knowing
that two plus two equals four.
The standard of realness for that is truth.
You're convinced that something is true and
it results in beliefs.
You get true beliefs, and perhaps they become
true justified beliefs, et cetera.
The kind of memory that's associated with
that is called semantic memory.
For example, if I ask you, "Do you remember
learning that cats are mammals?
Can you tell me the day that that really dropped
for you?"
And you go, "I don't know."
So that's semantic memory.
The reason why I'm saying this is all of these
memories are distinct from each other, such
that it's possible to damage one without the
others being completely damaged.
The next is procedural knowing.
This is knowing how, this is knowing how to
kiss someone.
This is knowing how to kick a ball.
This is knowing how to swim.
This doesn't result in beliefs.
This results in skills, and skills aren't
true or false.
Tim, do you know how to swim?
Tim Ferriss: I do.
John Vervaeke: Right.
Now, is swimming true or false right now?
No, you're misunderstanding.
Skills aren't true or false.
They apply or they don't, and they apply powerfully
or they don't.
And so it's standard of realness is powered.
Does our know-how empower us?
Then prosaically enough, psychologists called
a form of memory associated with this procedural
memory.
Now each one of these, I'm going in an order
of dependence.
The propositional depends on the procedural,
and we can get into that in a minute, but
I'll just go through the four first.
The next is perspectival knowing.
This is knowing what it's like to be.
So, you know what it's like to be you now
in your state of mind in this situation.
You know what you're foregrounding, what you're
backgrounding, you know what is salient for
you.
You can sense how the salience is shifting
around.
You got a sense of how you're fitted to this
situation.
This doesn't result in skills or beliefs.
It results in perspectives, and you know how
to take perspectives and you know what the
difference between perspectives are and how
valuable it is to have multi perspectives
on a situation.
Sometimes in order to solve a problem, you
shift to a different perspective.
And so perspectives aren't true or false,
they're not powerful or not, their standard
of realness is presence.
How present are you in this situation?
In fact, when people do VR work, they look
for this.
How much do people feel like they're in the
game?
There's that.
That's the perspectival knowing, that they're
really situated in it, that they really belong
to it, et cetera, et cetera.
This has its own kind of memory called episodic
memory.
So I can ask you perhaps, do you remember
what you did on your last birthday?
Tim Ferriss: And the answer's yes.
John Vervaeke: What you'll do is you'll remember
a particular perspective you had on a particular
situation and your state of mind in that situation.
That's your episodic memory.
Now below that, and this gets to what we were
talking about earlier, is participatory knowing.
This is knowing by being.
This is the kind of knowing that results from
how you and reality have been co-shaped to
fit together to generate those affordances.
For example, the water bottle and I have both
been shaped by gravity.
We've both been shaped by electromagnetism
so that we can — there's an affordance there.
We've both been shaped by a biological history,
which is niche construction.
My ancestors evolved.
They made tools that shaped the environment
that shaped my ancestors.
Culture has shaped me in this technology,
made this and taught me how to drink out of
a water bottle.
There's been all this co-shaping of me and
parts of the environment.
So we fit together, we're niche together,
we belong together.
Affordances are available to me.
The idea, and then that's carried in this
very weird sense of memory that you probably
don't even recognize is it's your sense of
self, the sense of all of the identities you've
taken up and how they're somehow historically
narratively linked together to certain narrative
histories of certain situations.
Here's the proposal.
You have participatory knowing.
It's laying out affordances.
When that's missing, you know it.
Culture shock or when you're homesick or when
you're lonely, that participatory knowing.
Tim Ferriss: John, could you do just define
affordances
John Vervaeke: The affordances are real relations
for how you can interact with the object and
how that object is available to you.
This affords graspability, the water bottle
is graspable.
That's an affordance, a real relation of fittedness,
so me and the water bottle belong together.
It makes itself available for certain interactions
and I can shape myself to interact with it
powerfully and appropriately.
Did that work as an explanation?
Tim Ferriss: It did work.
Could you perhaps give an example of an affordance
that would come into play with culture shock?
John Vervaeke: An affordance would come into
play with culture shock is there are certain
affordances about how you and other people
relate that tell you when conversation is
available to you, when there's an affordance
for conversation.
Notice that most of this is unconscious for
you.
Notice even within your own culture.
So Tim, how close should you stand to somebody
at a funeral?
Tim Ferriss: I was just thinking about the
body spacing because I was just in Japan where
it's very, very different.
I couldn't give you a discreet number, but
I was probably a feeling associated with it
where it goes from comfortable to uncomfortable.
John Vervaeke: Right.
You've got that sense of — and it wasn't
working in Japan.
Tim Ferriss: Very different.
John Vervaeke: And so that way of connecting
to people, by shaping the literal personal
space between you and them was not available
to you.
That affordance wasn't there.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that makes sense.
John Vervaeke: Okay.
The affordances are here, and then the perspectival
knowing makes certain affordances salient
to me, grabbing my attention, arousing my
metabolism.
The floor is walkable for me right now, but
I don't need to walk right now.
So it's not something that I'm paying attention
to, right?
But I bring it into my situational awareness
with the perspectival knowing, that situational
awareness tells me which skills I should activate,
which is procedural knowing.
Then the procedural knowing puts me into the
causal relationships with the world that give
me the evidence for my beliefs.
So that's all the kinds of knowing.
The point is, outside of the propositional,
these other kinds of knowing are built on
the way you are dynamically coupled to the
environment, and therefore, they harken back
to that participation, that contact we were
talking about.
Tim Ferriss: I suppose it's this coupling
and interaction with the environment on a
few different levels in the sense that you
have your sort of skin encapsulated ego and
its interaction with what we perceive as external
elements.
Then you have perhaps those who think of mind
and body in this Cartesian dualistic way.
You have the interaction of the body with
the mind, which in some respects is the entire
reason for which the brain evolved in some
respects.
Let me just come back to semantic memory.
Could you give just another example of semantic
memory, because I don't think I grasped that?
John Vervaeke: Oh.
So if I ask you, "Are dogs fishes?"
and what do you say to me?
Tim Ferriss: I say no.
John Vervaeke: That's semantic memory.
Did anybody ever sit you down, you remember
it?
Do you have an episodic memory of, "I remember
when I learned that dogs weren't fishes?"
It's not bound up with your particular perspective
on a situation or the state of mind you are
in.
It is this abstracted fact, and that's what
propositions are about.
They're about these abstracted facts.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
I've read somewhere, and I can't believe everything
I read on the internet, so I'd love for you
to fact check this.
Is there some interplay between what people
experience as flow states and the activation
or use of multiple forms of knowing?
Or did I just pull that out of the air?
John Vervaeke: No.
I have argued for that thesis.
I don't know if that makes it a fact, but
I would definitely argue on its behalf.
I think, well, I've published and done work
on the flow state, and I think the flow state
is an example of, in our experience, a prioritization
of the procedural, the perspectival, and the
participatory over the propositional.
In fact, one of the things people reliably
report is that whole propositional processing
drops out.
Even that narrative nanny, the thing in your
head that's like, "How am I doing?
How do I look?
Do people like me?
How am I doing?
Maybe I should lose some weight.
How's my hair," that all falls away.
Because you're so — well, this goes to what
I was saying a few minutes ago.
There's this enlivening, enriching of a sense
of contact.
One of the defining features of the flow state
is people feel at one with their environment.
They feel dynamically coupled to it.
So that's participatory.
They feel at one with it.
And the perspectival, everything is super
salient.
There's an ongoing sense of discovery of even
almost like insight in — well, I've argued
in insight cascade, you're getting even more
like the perspective, you're getting super
present.
Then of course the procedurality, is you just
know how to do it.
Hence the word, it just flows from you.
What's really important, Tim, is that the
flow state is optimal for people.
They think they're at their best with good
reason.
They'll say it's one of the best experiences
they had, one of the most rewarding, even
more rewarding than pleasure.
And so much so that asking people how frequently
they get into the flow state is a good predictor
of their sense of wellbeing.
And so here's the point I want to make about
that.
This is a clear example of that non-propositional
connectedness.
Flow is about really realizing the transjectivity,
that connectedness, and how much it contributes
to a sense of agency and meaning for people.
Tim Ferriss: I think we're going to jump in
the deep end of the meaning pool shortly.
Let me ask you first though, given what you
just said, how highly do you prioritize getting
into flow states yourself?
And if the answer is reasonably high or higher,
how do you personally like to get into flow
states?
John Vervaeke: I've said this, and I mean
this deeply, and I don't mean it as a trivial
commodification.
Daoism is the religion, philosophy of flow.
I've been practicing Daoist practices, Tai
Chi Chuan, Zhan Zhuang, Yi Chuan, Qigong.
I got professional training and practice for
10 years as a Shiatsu therapist.
I've done it all.
Well, not at all, that's pretentious.
But I've done a lot.
Okay, that's fair.
What those things do, and this is something
I want to talk to you about at some point,
they get me into a flow state, but in a particular
way that I think is really important.
And this goes to a story I've told.
I was in grad school and I'd been doing Tai
Chi Chuan for about three or four years.
I was doing it really religiously, both in
the sense of devotedly, and I was doing it
two or three hours a day and going to the
dojo three or four times a week kind of thing.
Some of my fellow students came up to me and
said, "What's going on with you?
What are you doing differently?"
I'm like, "Oh, you're worried in grad school
that people are going to find you out."
And so I said, "I'm doing Tai Chi Chuan."
Well, before I said that, and I said, "Well,
why are you saying that?"
And they said, "Well, because you're just
— in conversations, you're much more flowing
and you're much more flexible and you're much
more balanced and you're much more receptive.
And you seem to..."
And it was like, "Oh, the flow state that
I'm getting into in Tai Chi is permeating
many different domains of my life and many
different levels of my mind."
I thought, ah, and this is a question that
has become a question to me.
What are the contexts that generate flow that
transfer like that powerfully, versus the
context where the flow stays locked into that
particular context?
Tim Ferriss: That is a great question.
That is such a good question.
So where have you gone with that?
John Vervaeke: Well, I've gone with that,
well, in several different directions, and
it's very much a work in progress.
I asked for some charity on the part of listeners.
This is something I'm very much working on
right now.
I'm glad you think it's a great question because
even if you get a good question that then
you're a good scientist, then you're doing
something.
One of the things I think has to do with whether
or not the skill or the skillset that's being
trained in the particular practice pick is
relatively indispensable in domains other
than the situation you're in.
Now, ideas about sensory motor movement and
balance and coordination and getting the cerebellum
and the frontal cortex to talk better to each
other, that transfers broadly.
We've already got a lot of evidence about
that, especially the cerebellum cortex loop.
Even when people are meditating, the cerebellum
is firing like crazy because of the cerebellum
cortex loop.
And so if it does that, then it could even
shows up in the metaphors.
We talk about balancing equations and justice
being the balancing of things and scales.
And so you want to find a set of skills that
has that inbuilt potential.
Then what I would want to say is the degree
to which there has been a framework built
around the situation, a ritual philosophical
framework that helps to afford the translation.
So around the Tai Chi Chuan, you have Daoism,
which gives you this way of framing reality
as yin and yang that you can see instantiated
in the Tai Chi, but you can also see it prevalent
in the world.
And so you set up the possibility with this
framework for the resonance.
And so people who get trapped, and I'm not
saying that all video games trap people, but
the ones that suffer from video game addiction,
they get the problem that they flow in a world
that does not have a framework around it,
it does not tap into those generally transferrable
skills.
And so they find the external world depressing
because of its absence of flow potential that
drives them into the game where they flow.
And then you get the vicious cycle that gets
you into the addiction.
I think there's something about what are the
kinds of skills that are being brought into
the flow state.
Do they have this domain general power?
Is there a framework around it that helps
people set up these patterns of resonance
between what they're doing in the practice
and how they're seeing the world and encountering
it?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it makes a lot of sense
to me.
If there is some overarching philosophical
framework or religious framework for that
matter within which you're practicing a given
skill, there's a broader context that then
extends whatever you're honing in this specific
situation to other domains.
It makes me think actually of a friend of
mine, his name is Joshua Waitzkin.
He was the basis for Searching for Bobby Fischer,
the book and the movie, of course, very, very
high-level chess player.
But he talks a lot.
He no longer plays chess.
He does a million other things.
He was actually world champion in Tai Chi
Push Hands.
And what I find most, I shouldn't say most
interesting.
He's a lovely, deeply soulful guy.
It's not that I'm looking at him as a sort
of instrument of learning mastery, but he
is able to take concepts from all these different
disciplines and apply them and transfers to
all these other things.
For instance, in chess, he talks a lot about
practicing the macro in the micro, or learning
the macro from the micro.
He'll say, "Yeah, chess people, often novices,
will, say, practice openings, but that's kind
of like copying from the teacher's answer
book."
You're memorizing a lot in terms of declarative
knowledge, but you're not learning principles.
So he'll say, "Why don't you start with — let's
just say three or four or five pieces on the
board and you're going to practice manipulating
empty space or pulling into a vacuum."
Lo and behold, a lot of those same principles
transferred over to Tai Chi, and then he took
principles from Tai Chi and moved them over
into foil boarding.
Is Tai Chi your go-to break-glass-in-case-of-emergency
tool in the department of flow states, or
do you have other approaches in the quiver?
John Vervaeke: Yeah, and this comes from the
Socratic part of my framework, if you want
to put it that way.
That sounds very pretentious.
Tim Ferriss: I'm into it.
John Vervaeke: I have learned how to get into
the flow state when lecturing.
And that inevitably affords really good learning.
Of course, not for every student, that would
be claiming something that's impossible.
No teacher is a great teacher to every student.
But I mean I've won teaching awards, et cetera,
et cetera, and that's because of this.
Very often, students get drawn into it because
I encourage a lot of Socratic dialogue in
the lecture.
And so it very much often becomes a shared
flow state.
I become very interested in shared flow states
and what they mean for how we can unpack the
capacity for insight and reflection.
So that's one of my other go-to areas.
Tim Ferriss: So let's unpack that a little
bit.
So in lecturing, did you do that naturally
from the outset?
Kind of like Usain Bolt having just different
tendon attachments and so on, you can just
run fast.
So did that come out of the box for you or
was that shared flow state in the form of
lecturing a learned skill?
If so, how did you develop that?
John Vervaeke: So very much a cultivated thing,
and deliberately so.
By nature, I'm almost pathologically shy and
so I didn't realize it was a lesson from Aristotle
at the time, but you cultivate your character
to compensate for your personality defects.
And so I adopted — I've read my report cards
from grade three, and they were calling me
mini teacher.
So taking on the role of the teacher, and
I was fortunate to have some really wonderful
teachers that allowed this, and to have classmates
that enjoyed it.
Think of all the conditions of how that could
have gone wrong.
So very fortunate, and that was how I started
to manage that situation.
So Tim —
Tim Ferriss: And manage that situation, you
mean manage your shyness by —
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Assuming the role of teacher?
Right.
The full persona and the role.
So Tim, this is close enough to teaching,
and I don't mean to put you in the role of
a student, I'm not saying that, but it's close
enough.
It's in proximity for transfer.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I'm a student.
John Vervaeke: Yep.
Well, anyways, it's comfortable, but if you
were to meet me if at a social party, I'm
at times indistinguishable from potted plants,
right?
Because when I don't have that role available
to me, my natural constitution comes out.
So it is very deliberately cultivated from
very, very early on.
And then as I started doing Tai Chi Chuan,
when I started in grad school hearing about
the bleed, that's when I started to teach
and lecture and I looked for it and I looked
for what broke it and what enhanced it, and
I slowly cultivated it more and more over
time.
Yes, it was very much a deliberate long-term
cultivation.
Tim Ferriss: So what enhances it?
Because you take, let's just grab an example
out of the year, Harvard Business School.
They have these case study methods and there
is ostensibly supposed to be a fair amount
of interplay between lecture and student,
but I would imagine that not all professors
or grad students, or whoever is doing the
teaching at the time would say they achieve
a flow state, even if they've experienced
it in other places like surfing.
So what have you found to be things that enhance
that for yourself and for the students?
John Vervaeke: So part of this, I'm going
to declare a bias because I have a published
theory about what I think the flow state is.
I think it's an insight cascade and the enhancement
of implicit learning.
So in enhance, we cultivate better insight
capacities, we cultivate better intuition
in an integrated manner.
Now, that ghost, so I'm stating the bias upfront,
but I think it's a good theory and I think
it's well argued and well evidenced, but what
I mean by that is more and more I crafted
giving priority to the emergence of insight
or intuition in me as I was lecturing and
not sticking to the script so strongly, but
willing to bend.
So I use the jazz analogy.
I may have the script of the lecture, but
I can riff on it and I look and I hunger and
sensitize myself for that.
And then when the students start to even demonstrate
proto insight, I will really call that out
in a positive manner and draw it out and they
get — and they start priming each other
with insights and they start priming me and
I start priming them.
And so it's an easy thing to state and it's
a hard thing to do because when you're lecturing
and when I teach people how to lecture, I
actually try to say, I try to get them to
make space for the jazz because what you do
when you're anxious, and one of the things
that really kills it a lot, it's PowerPoint,
right?
Because what you want is, "I need to say all
of these things and I need to be clear and
I need to have everything follow."
And so you get really, you try to constrain
your anxiety with the tightness of this structure
that you built.
And what that actually does is that undermines
the possibility of flow.
And so it's like Tai Chi Chuan, right?
You want to be pung, you don't want to be
too yin, too yang.
You want loosen the structure enough so that
insight and intuition flow, but not so much
that the lecture becomes incoherent and you
find the sweet spot.
Tim Ferriss: How did you find Tai Chi, or
how did Tai Chi find you?
John Vervaeke: I was brought up in a fundamentalist
Christian extended family, not just the nuclear
family, extended family.
And it's only later that I've come to realize
how traumatizing that was for me.
And so when I was 15, I read a couple of books,
The Lord of Light and Siddhartha, Lord of
Light by Roger Zelazny, Siddhartha by Hermann
Hesse, Fifth Business by Robertson Davies,
and it really blew me open.
It really blew me open.
And so I left the Christianity, and like I
said, I've done some therapy and other things,
but religion, your mother religion is like
your mother tongue.
It shapes you in a way that nothing else ever
can, or your first love.
You don't necessarily stay with that person,
but it shapes you in very interesting ways
in your relationships.
And so if you'll allow me a metaphor, it left
a taste for the transcendent in my mouth.
And then I got to university and I took a
first year course in philosophy and I encountered
the figure of Socrates and the project of
wisdom and it was like, that's it.
And of course, that is still with me now.
That's how profound it hit me, how profoundly.
But what happened — and then I went into
philosophy.
What happened in philosophy, academic philosophy,
now it's changing now, but we're talking about
a long time ago, the '80s, the topic of wisdom,
self-transcendence, all these kinds of things
that are rich in the Platonic corpus and the
right and the Neoplatonic, it drops off the
table and you talk about skepticism and epistemology
and these are valuable metascientific and
metacultural skills and I value them, but
that hunger for the cultivation of wisdom
was not being met.
And I happened to live in a place where literally
down the road there was the Tai Chi and Meditation
Center.
So I thought, "You know what?
I'm going to give the Eastern philosophies
a try and maybe they will give me what I need
for satisfying this hunger for the cultivation
of wisdom."
And I was very lucky again because first of
all, wonderful people.
And secondly, this is where I got what I would
now call an ecology of practices.
They didn't teach me one thing.
They taught me a meditative practice, Vipassana.
They taught me a contemplative practice, metta.
And then they taught me Tai Chi Chuan to get
how to flow between them in a regular and
reliable ecology of practices.
And that's how it happened and that has been
with me ever since.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Vipassana, metta and Tai Chi, that is a very
potent and uncommon trinity there.
That's a very formidable combination of things
and I do want to revisit at some point meditation
as contrasted with contemplation.
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: But first, I'd like to ask you,
how old were you when you decided to leave
Christianity and what was that experience
like?
John Vervaeke: 15.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
John Vervaeke: And my life became bifurcated
and fragmented in a way that I came to deeply
find distasteful.
And so trying to deal with fragmentation has
also become a pervasive theme, whether it's
fragmentation within a person or fragmentation
between the different disciplines that study
the mind.
That's why I'm in cognitive scientists trying
to integrate and solve the fragmentation problem.
It was very challenging for me because I couldn't
move out on my own or anything.
I'm 15.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, right.
John Vervaeke: I'm still in my family and
they knew that something was going on, and
there was this weird don't ask, don't tell
thing.
It was very challenging me.
There were times when I went to church and
the minister would be getting everybody to
bow their head and raise their hand as if
they agreed with this.
And of course, everybody's looking around
surreptitiously and everybody's raising their
hand and I'm the one person not raising my
hand.
And just very, very, very difficult.
And then of course there was a group of friends,
close friends at high school that were — they
became very much invested in this project
that I was engaged in of wrestling with meaning.
And so they became very supportive and that
was very happy for me but that was — and
it caused things and it caused me to get married
too young because marrying was a way of escaping
that fundamentalist family and setting up
a new one.
And I'm on good terms with my ex, and I'm
not making any criticisms of her.
I'm just saying we got married, I think too
young because we were both escaping that and
we both — and that's a good reason for forming
a company together for a while, like the fellowship
of the ring or something.
We're both going to leave fundamentalism together,
we're going to help — but it's not the basis
for a long-term marriage.
It's not.
And of course, you don't know this at the
time, the ways in which I was foolish around
this are significant, but I was wrestling
with a lot of stuff.
I was wrestling with a profound kind of depression.
I used to call it the black burning in my
chest because of that hole.
Like I said —
Tim Ferriss: I can imagine.
John Vervaeke: But also, like I said, there
was trauma.
There's instances from when I was still in
it as a kid that were absolutely traumatic
to me.
I came home one day and I lived within walking
distance of the school.
And there was always somebody in the home
just because of the way it was a small home.
We were a poor family.
There was kids, my mom was mostly a housewife,
and I came home once and there was nobody
there.
And I was absolutely convinced to my bones
that the Rapture had occurred, all my family
had been taken away.
I was too sinful.
I was left behind and the Antichrist and his
minions were coming for me.
This is, I'm 10.
And then another one, I used to read the Bible
every day, and I'm glad I have, by the way.
Biblical literacy is really important part
of cultural literacy.
I don't begrudge that and the Bible still
is deeply meaningful to me, but I read this
passage in the New Testament and in multiple
places they talk about the unforgivable sin,
the sin that can never be forgiven no matter
how much you pray about it, and I was terrified.
And I thought, "Have I committed...?"
Again, I think I was like 12.
"Have I committed the unforgivable sin?
And is thinking that the unforgivable sin?"
And my mother could tell I was getting deeply
distressed, and she took me to the minister
who was supposed to help me, and he just gave
me empty platitudes that even as a 12-year-old
I recognized were completely useless, and
I realized he doesn't have an answer to this.
He pretended he had — he spoke with the
confidence of some — but there was no answer
forthcoming, and it was just like that kind
of trauma.
And these are just a couple incidences of
many.
And again, I'm not villianizing my mom or
my dad or my family.
I love them.
My mom and my dad are both dead.
I love my extended family but this is when
I stepped out of that, that now came to the
fore like, "Well, you've got to address this.
What is the world such that?
You shouldn't have these fears.
You shouldn't have these terrors.
What do you do with the way that has made
you afraid of things?"
So yeah, it took work, it took therapy, it
took meditation, contemplation, Tai Chi Chuan,
a lot of good education, especially in the
Socratic, Platonic tradition.
So that's what it was like.
I wouldn't recommend it for anybody but the
thing I have to tell you, Tim, is I meet a
lot of people who are attracted to my work
because of something similar like this happening
to them.
They have left a religious home and they do
not find any religious homes viable, yet they
still hunger for that deep connectedness,
that meaning, that space in which one can
cultivate wisdom.
Tim Ferriss: Let's segue to this word "wisdom,"
because this might sound strange, but the
self transcendence and the experience of that,
I have some, I suppose, experience that lends
itself to understanding what that means.
Wisdom though, I would love for you to define
for us, just so everybody including myself,
is on the same page?
John Vervaeke: Knowledge is about overcoming
ignorance.
Wisdom is about overcoming foolishness.
So you understand wisdom by understanding
foolishness, and you understand foolishness
as not identical to ignorance.
These are the moods you have to make to get
the chess pieces on the board if you want
to play the game we're going to play.
And so foolishness, what is it?
What do we mean by this?
And this is an idea that's born in the Axial
Revolution, this specific notion of foolishness.
But this idea, and I think 4E cogsci bears
it out, I argue for it, I publish about it.
The very processes that make us intelligent
problem solvers, make us so adaptive, are
the very same processes that make us prone
to self-deceptive, self-destructive behavior,
right?
That you don't get one without the other.
So you use your intelligence to solve problems,
but you use rationality and wisdom to deal
with the self-deception that emerges as you're
trying to solve your problems, and that's
a very different thing.
And the thing about these self deceptions
is they don't come as sort of isolated little
things.
They can constellate into complex patterns
of self-organization.
The confirmation bias can strengthen egocentrism,
which can strengthen the degree to which you
engage in a kind of narrow framing of situations,
which can then feed back into the — and
we've published on this, you get these massively
complex.
So the dynamical complex self-organization
of your cognition is hijacked by self-deceptive
processes, and they form these systems that
are also complex and adaptive and hard to
intervene on.
We call it parasitic processing in the work
that Leo and I published.
Right?
Tim Ferriss: John, would you mind giving an
example, because there are people listening,
I'm sure a lot of people listening who pride
themselves on being good problem solvers,
having strong analytical minds, and they're
like, "But I don't see how that automatically
begets — not automatically, but how that
would beget delusion, self-deception."
Would you mind giving an example or a hypothetical?
John Vervaeke: Let's use a chess example.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
John Vervaeke: Here's the problem facing you
in chess.
You can't actually check all the possible
alternative pathways for playing a chess game.
The number of alternative pathways is greater
than the number of atomic particles in the
universe.
So even the super fastest chess game can't
check all of the possible alternative sequences
of actions.
That's why, by the way, you get a chess game
that beats any human being, or let's do it
with go.
You get AlphaGo beats any human being, but
then you can make a machine that beats AlphaGo
because no game is — no AI can algorithmically
play and search.
So what we have to do is we have to bias what
information we check.
This is the paradox.
It sounds like a Zen koan, right?
You're intelligent because of your ability
to ignore so much information in a way that
makes obvious to you the relevant information
enough of the time that you're a very good
problem solver in very many, many domains.
So you're playing chess.
What's a good heuristic?
Control the center board.
I've played with somebody who was controlling
the center board, I realized that they were
biasing their attention that way.
And so I played a peripheral game and beat
them because they focused on — now, should
people not focus on the center board?
Well, no, it's a very good heuristic, but
it's heuristic.
It's not an algorithm.
This is a formal thing.
It's called the No Free Lunch Theorem.
There is no problem solving method that will
universally solve all your problems.
In fact, the area above the line of average
problem solving where it's improving your
performance is equal to an area under the
line where it degrades your performance.
Every bias is just as heuristic, misfiring,
and every heuristic is just a bias that happens
to be working for us in a lot of context.
They're interchangeable together.
And so even when you're doing analytic stuff,
right?
You're confronting this, you often realize
the way you've framed the problem is actually
what's preventing you from solving the problem.
You have to have that aha moment that breaks
you out of it.
But when you're trapped in it, that's a form
of self-deception.
You can't really lie to yourself.
What you do is you bias your attention to
find the wrong thing salient in a way that
binds you to trying to solve it in a particular
manner.
This shows up in interpersonal context.
I'm sure you've had something like this as
an experience.
"Oh, I thought she was angry, but she's afraid.
She's afraid, not angry.
I've been going at this all wrong."
Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
John Vervaeke: That doesn't mean that sometimes
people aren't angry at you and you shouldn't
see them as angry at you, right?
And so even the most analytic thing you're
doing is dependent on — pure logic, you're
going in to do a logic class.
This is from my history, and a lot of people
will back me up on this.
For a while, what you're doing is you're practicing
doing all the machinery of the transformations
and the logic trees and all the derivations,
and you just got to practice that.
And then you realize, "But I'm still not getting
really — I'm still only getting Bs and lower
As, what's going on?"
And you keep getting docked, not on the logic,
but how you translated natural language into
the logic, for which there is no logical procedure.
And so that translation process is needed
in order to get the logical machinery running,
but it is not itself governed in a purely
logical manner.
It requires this flexibility, this reframing,
this insight, this kind of stuff.
Tim Ferriss: I wanted to invoke a word you
mentioned in passing with respect to flow
states in lectures, which was intuition.
John Vervaeke: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: And so I wanted to loop that
in to ask — well, you can pick and choose.
This is interviewee's choice.
So one would be how do you think about intuition
versus logic when it comes to problem solving
or searching for meaning or finding meaning?
Alternative question would be what kinds of
problems is logic poorly suited to solving?
John Vervaeke: Sure.
And so we'll do that and then I'll tell you
what I think intuition is and what the powers
and perils of it are.
Tim Ferriss: Great.
John Vervaeke: So the search space, the search
space for very, very many problems, like the
chess example, is combinatorially explosive.
It's computationally intractable and this
is the seminal work of Newell and Simon and
then Simon and his notion of bounded rationality,
and this is the idea that you can't be comprehensively
logical.
Logic and math are algorithmic.
They work in terms of certainty.
Certainty requires that you search sometimes
all or at least most of the space, and if
you tried to do that, you would've committed
cognitive suicide.
That would be the last thing you do and that
can't be a rational way to behave.
So bounded rationality is something more like
knowing where, when, how, and to what degree?
Using all the non-propositional kinds of knowing
to tell you where, when, how, and what degree
you should be logical?
You have to cultivate these virtues for when
you use logic.
So that's what rationality is and that's a
much harder problem.
"When should I be logical?"
And so you have to ask yourself, "If I formulate
the problem such that the search space could
be searched in a relatively exhaustive fashion,
and there are algorithms that work that, how
many people are present in this conversation?"
There's an algorithm counting, "Two, one,
two, we're done.
There, that worked."
There was nothing wrong with doing that, right?
But if you try to say, "I want to count all
the numbers of possible conversations we could
have and thereby try to figure out invariant
principles through all conversations," it's
like, well, what's a conversation?
And I've been in many ones and there's good
ones and there's bad ones, but the good ones
are aren't — they're sort of the same, they're
similar to each other.
And the problem with similarity, and this
is now the main argument, is if you try to
be logical about similarity, you're doomed
because —
Tim Ferriss: What do you mean by that?
What do you mean by logical about similarity?
John Vervaeke: Yeah, I do.
So this is an argument made by Nelson Goodman,
what a great name for a philosopher, Nelson
Goodman.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, outstanding.
John Vervaeke: 1972, and the argument goes
like this.
So identity is to share all properties.
Similarity is to share a lot of properties,
but not share all properties, kind of the
same as Sesame Street used to say.
So he said, "Pick up any two objects and you'll
find that there's an indefinitely large number
of properties they share."
So a plum and a lawnmower, they both have
curved surfaces, they're both shiny, they're
both found in North America, both contain
carbon, both weigh more than a paperclip.
Neither one is a particularly good weapon.
How many true things can I say that apply
to both?
Tim Ferriss: Those —
John Vervaeke: Indefinitely large.
Tim Ferriss: Indefinitely large.
John Vervaeke: Right.
And that's the case for anything.
So if you try to have a logic of similarity,
it will not pick out — it won't help you
sort the world at all.
So what people rely on is psychological similarity,
which is they say to you things like, "But
none of those properties..."
And here's the key term, "None of those properties
are the relevant properties.
Those aren't the important ones."
And of course, relevance and importance are
not features of a proposition.
The same proposition can be relevant one minute
and irrelevant the next.
This is actually a formal argument by Jerry
Fodor and others.
Relevance is not a logical property.
If what we mean by logical properties are
syntactic relations within propositions and
implication relations between them, you can't
capture relevance with those syntactic relations
and therefore you can't do a logic of similarity.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe this is a good place, you
can chastise me if it isn't, but to bring
in and define intuition and the powers and
perils thereof.
And to the extent that you could maybe share
how you harness the powers and avoid the perils
personally.
I think that would make it easy to grasp for
folks, myself included.
John Vervaeke: Excellent, excellent.
Oh, wonderful, wonderful.
So I'm deeply influenced by two things: Csikszentmihalyi's
work on Flow and Hogarth's work, Educating
Intuition, and he makes a proposal, and I
think this is the best proposal I've heard.
So if we're doing inferences to the best explanation,
it's the best explanation.
So we've had a robust research program from
the late '60s, starting with Arthur Reber
for what's called implicit learning.
So I'm sorry, I need a minute to describe
the experimental paradigm for this because
—
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
John Vervaeke: So what you do is you create
an artificial grammar for how you're allowed
to string numbers and letters together.
The grammar might have the rule, you can't
have two odd numbers beside each other.
You can't have two vowels beside each other.
You can't have more than four consonants in
a row or something like this, and you make
these by completely arbitrary artificial grammar.
You make these number-letter strings that
are like nine or 12 long.
So you can't hold them easily in working memory
or anything like that.
And so what you do is you give people and
you say, "This is one, this is one," not quite
this fast, but I'm just doing it.
You hold up these strings and you get people
to look at them and there's various modifications.
Sometimes you give feedback, but that's just
the basic paradigm.
Now, here's what you do.
Tim Ferriss: So you're not giving them the
rules in advance.
Is that correct?
John Vervaeke: No.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So this is purely deductive.
You're just giving them examples, since I'm
—
John Vervaeke: Well, I'm going to say it's
not deductive but —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it's not.
Oh, okay.
John Vervaeke: They're purely just doing — they're
doing this.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
John Vervaeke: I'll say what I think it is
in a minute.
Okay.
And I'll say why it's not deductive because
of an experimental variation.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
John Vervaeke: So I'm not just going to swipe
that aside.
I'm going to address your point.
Okay, so you do this and you do this, and
you do this and you do this.
And then what you do is you say, "Now I'm
going to give you a bunch of strings."
And what you do is some of those strings are
new, they haven't appeared yet, but they're
generated by the same artificial grammar.
And then some are generated by a completely
alternative or even randomly generated.
And then you present them to people and you
say, "Which of these new strings belongs with
the old ones?"
And people reliably score well above chance
on this, well above chance.
Okay.
So what people have is the capacity without
explicit awareness or deliberate effort, they
can pick up on very complex patterns.
Now, why isn't it deduction?
Because if you do the following and you say,
"I'm going to give you the strings, and I
want you to figure out the rules that are
generating the strings," their performance
degrades and they actually fall below chance,
they get really worse.
Tim Ferriss: They get all tangled up in themselves.
John Vervaeke: Yes.
So what Hogarth proposes is that intuition
is a result of implicit learning.
You're picking up on very complex patterns
without explicit awareness or deliberate effort.
You know how close to stand to somebody at
a funeral, but it depends on their status,
their closeness to the person, their emotional
state, how you are feeling.
It depends on all of these variables, but
it depends on what part of the funeral it
is.
It depends on potential religious, there's
all these variables and they're interacting
in complex dynamic ways.
And you've picked that up and you don't know
how you've picked it up.
You don't know where and when.
So you just get the intuition, "I should stand
this close," and you do it, and you're right.
Now, what's the peril of this?
So that's its power.
You pick up on complex patterns and you don't
do it deductively.
And I gave you the evidence for that, right?
So what's the peril with this?
And this is Hogarth's work, and I think it's
powerful.
Implicit learning doesn't care what patterns
it picks up.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
John Vervaeke: It doesn't distinguish real
causal patterns from correlational patterns,
and there's a lot more complex correlational
patterns that aren't real causal patterns.
And so we pick up on all kinds of complex
patterns that are not real and we form intuitions
around them, but when we don't like our intuition,
we don't call it intuition, we call it bias
or prejudice or racism or sexism or a whole
bunch of other things.
Right?
And so Hogarth says, "Well, what should we
do?"
We can't replace implicit learning with explicit
learning.
What can we do explicitly?
And he says, "Well, what we can do is set,
we can explicitly set up the situation in
which we're doing implicit learning, that
replicates how science distinguishes cause
from correlation," because that's what science
is.
It's a practice for distinguishing cause from
correlation.
So what are those?
Well, you need clear feedback, you need clear
information.
You need clear and tightly coupled feedback,
error has to matter.
You can falsify the experiment and you set
that up.
And if you're learning in those situations,
chances are your implicit learning will track
causal patterns rather than correlational.
And then you ask me, "How do you do that,
John?"
Well, here's John's answer.
Csikszentmihalyi says, "How do you get into
the flow state?
What are the informational constraints?
The information has to be clear, it has to
be tightly coupled, and error has to matter."
The exact three conditions that Hogarth proposes
for making sure you're doing good implicit
learning are exactly the conditions that get
people reliably into the flow state.
And so we've published on that what flow state
is, it's an evolutionary marker that you're
getting a lot of insight and you're getting
a lot of insight within implicit learning
that is probably tracking real causal relationships.
So whatever you're doing, keep doing it because
chances are you're really figuring out the
environment in a powerful way.
Tim Ferriss: What have you done with this
knowledge?
How has that informed your behaviors or beliefs
as you operate in the world?
John Vervaeke: I try to make sure that we're
setting up the explicit circumstance for flow
states that have a lot of those conditions
in them.
This goes towards work I'm doing on shared
flow states when people are getting into dialogically
shared flow states, dia-logos, and what are
the contexts we can build around that so that
we can get people more reliably having insight
cascades and tracking real patterns of sense-making
as opposed to weird, funky correlational things?
Tim Ferriss: So I am going to double click
on dia-logos because I've mentioned dialogue
and wanting to get into the etymology of that
just because I'm a nerd about all that stuff.
But before we get there, could you could give
a personal example of how you have used this
insight and knowledge based on the studies
and the work of these various people you've
mentioned, and of course your own publications,
how has that informed how you operate in the
world or make decisions?
John Vervaeke: So it's made me a lot more
careful about where I might be.
So first of all, it's given me a way of challenging
a certain kind of decadent romanticism in
the culture, which says that you should always
trust your intuition.
There is no panacea faculty, there is no panacea
practice, no free lunch theorem.
And I have become too — I've become — I
don't know what — almost like a preacher
or something.
I'd be almost evangelical about trying to
say stop demonizing any faculty and stop deifying
any faculty.
Your intuition will lead you as much wrong
as your reason, as much wrong as your emotions,
as much wrong as whatever, as much wrong as
your logic, right?
Look, logic does not tell you how to go from
a weaker logic to a stronger logic.
I can do all the possible manipulations within
predicate logic and it won't get me to motor
logic.
I have to do something outside of that to
actually increase my logical competence.
So there's no panacea.
There's no panacea.
So that has become like I have taken that
up as a theme and I do it.
I do it for myself.
This is why I advocate very strongly for,
and I was fortunate to be taught, an ecology
of practices.
I do not practice.
I practice a bunch of practices that have
complimentary strengths and weaknesses that
are constantly checking each other and calling
each other out and constraining each other
and pointing out errors in each other like
an ecology, how you have the checks and balances
in a biological ecosystem.
That is how it had a huge impact on how I
try to cultivate wisdom and virtue and how
I recommend to others how they should do it.
I strongly advocate for practicing an ecology
of practices that is well-designed and what
are some of the design principles for a good
ecology of practices.
And then I feed that back into my own practices
and how I try to teach other people.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So I would love to know how you have improved,
maybe let me rephrase that.
What questions you have asked yourself to
improve your ability to spot spurious or at
the very least unhelpful forms of pattern
recognition.
Right?
So the intuition we want to avoid and how
you've done that, because I've observed certainly,
and I'm sure you have, and I'm sure I do it
in my own way.
People who are very methodical about testing
in some scientific empirical fashion, causality
and, say, engineering.
So they're doing split testing in their job
as an engineer, and then as soon as they jump
into the world of, say, nutrition or fill
in the blank, it all falls apart.
And they just seem to founder in spotting
all these sort of correlations that they turn
into causation in a really kind of sloppy
way.
And I'm sure I do it as well.
So how have you improved your ability to spot
that for yourself?
John Vervaeke: Well, I don't want to in any
way try to convey that I don't fall prey to
this.
How have I tried to address it is how I'll
frame the question you've asked me.
Tim Ferriss: Perfect.
John Vervaeke: Okay.
And so first of all, that issue that we were
talking about earlier, how pervasively does
your practice transfer to multiple domains
and to multiple levels of your psyche?
How much does it engage the non-propositional
kinds of knowing?
How much is it engaging the ability to metacognitively
shift between perspectives, et cetera?
For exactly that reason.
Secondly, it's not the questions you answer,
it's practices you do at length for considerable
amount of time.
I practiced.
First of all, I practiced it very explicitly
for two or three years, and this overlaps
significantly with Stoicism, right?
I practice active open-mindedness like I'm
a cognitive scientist, learn about the biases
and this is how you get into it.
Learn about the biases and first spot them
in other people.
You'll be astonishingly good at that.
Oh, confirmation bias, myside bias, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
You're really good at fundamental attribution
error.
You're really good at it with other people
and get real and allow yourself to be sort
of overconfident a bit.
And then practice at the second stage, which
is try to note every day a bias in your own
and actively counteract it.
Oh wait, this is confirmation bias.
Where would I look for evidence that could
disconfirm this?
Or who could I talk to who would challenge
me on this?
You have to practice it.
It's not about getting a rule or a technique
of question.
It's about developing a deeply ingrained habit
that helps to work.
And in concert with this, and this is also
from Stoicism.
Stoicism is the philosophy religion of internalizing
Socrates and practicing internalizing Socrates.
Tim Ferriss: This is Antisthenes.
Am I getting that pronunciation right?
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Yeah, exactly, exactly, right.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
John Vervaeke: Now what did you learn from
Socrates?
I learned how to dialogue with myself, but
he didn't mean the way we all talk to ourselves
in our head all day long.
And you have to practice that.
You have to practice it on your own.
I have to practice it with others.
And I've been doing that, and I've been developing
ways of honing that.
We do these weekend workshops.
I do it with Guy Sengstock and Christopher
Mastropietro.
We take people through a meditation practice,
a contemplation practice, then various circling
practices, then various paraphrasing practices.
And then we get them to do sort of a shared
Lectio Divina around a philosophical text
where they learn to resonate with each other
around —
Tim Ferriss: Lectio Divina.
I don't know what that means, but I like the
sound of it.
John Vervaeke: And then we take them into
a particular way of engaging in dialectic
into dia-logos.
And you have to practice this and you have
to read the dialogues and you have to internalize,
you have to internalize the sage.
And this is one of the — just the athlete
has to internalize the coach, just like the
child has to internalize the parent.
And that again is not a magic technique, it's
something you have to practice consistently
as a way of life and degree to which I've
internalized Socrates and the degree to which
I've cultivated habits of active open-mindedness,
the degree to which I've sought out the company
of people who will challenge me in the right
ways because people can be also — criticize
you in the wrong ways.
So it takes discernment.
That's how I'm trying to address what you've
asked me.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So I want to attempt to create a bridge between
what you just said and do so for the listeners
and to do so by giving some examples of the
forms of exercises that you mentioned in passing.
And this is also a way of delivering on the
promise I made earlier to people that we would
get into meditation versus contemplation.
So could you give an example?
And I apologize if this is sort of asking
for a heavy lift, but yeah, I think it would
be helpful for me and hopefully maybe for
listeners.
John Vervaeke: I'll try my best.
Tim Ferriss: So you mentioned meditation,
I'm sure I'm going to miss something, contemplation,
circling, I don't know what that means, paraphrasing,
I believe.
Lectio Divina, am I getting that right?
John Vervaeke: Well, actually the practice
is a variation on it called philosophical
fellowship.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, perfect.
So could you walk us through these and just
give an example of an exercise, what that
might look like in each of those?
John Vervaeke: Sure.
So I mean, first of all, the distinction between
meditation and contemplation.
So I know this is audio only, so I wear glasses,
right?
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
John Vervaeke: Right, right.
And so I'm —
Tim Ferriss: And we'll probably also use the
video, but just for those people who only
have the audio, it's always helpful to tell
them what's going on.
Yes.
John Vervaeke: So I've been talking throughout
about how you frame situations, what you make
salient, what you background and what you
ignore.
So think about that like the lens and the
frame of my glasses, right?
And I'm not aware of my lenses or my frame
because I'm aware through them, beyond them
and by means of them.
So they're transparent to me.
Now sometimes, and what I'm doing right now,
everyone, I'm taking my glasses off because
there might be something on my lenses and
now they're not transparent to me.
I'm not looking through them, I'm looking
at them.
That's what meditation is.
It's about trying to become aware, step back
and look at your mental framing.
So what you do is, for example, you try to
get people to look at something they're normally
looking through, like their sensations.
So for example, I teach people how to center,
but they're following their breath.
And you want to follow the whole of your breath
going in, and you want to feel the sensations
of the breath and of the expansion of your
abdomen, and then sensations of your abdomen
contracting and the breath coming out.
And what happens is, right, you're paying
attention to the sensations and very quickly
your mind goes to, "No, I want to look through
things.
I want to look at the world.
Now I should be doing my laundry.
Or when is the meditation going to be done?
Or I wonder if Susan still likes me."
And then what you do is you step back and
look at that distraction.
You don't look at what you're thinking about.
You label the process, thinking, imagining,
hoping, wondering, and then you return your
attention to your breath.
And so what you're doing is you're learning
to step back and look at your framing.
Now think about this, even in the analogy,
if I just take my glasses off and look at
them and maybe I wipe them and I wipe them
and I wipe them and I wipe them, how do I
know if I've actually cleaned them?
What do I need to do?
Tim Ferriss: Got to put them back on.
John Vervaeke: You've got to put them back
on and see if you now see more clearly and
deeply than you used to before.
That is contemplation.
It comes from the Latin word contemplatio,
which is a translation of the Greek word theoria,
which is where we get our word theory from,
which means to look deeply into reality.
So Vipassana is this act of I'm stepping back
and looking at, but metta is the contemplative.
I'm trying to look, I'm trying to see if — how
can I see you better than I used to?
So in metta, I'm trying to open up and see
if I can see you better, or I may contemplate
the impermanence of existence.
I'm trying to see, I'm trying, not in — I'm
not just thinking or saying, I'm trying to
realize the impermanence of things.
That's a contemplative act.
It's a direction outward.
Tim Ferriss: And for folks who are familiar
with metta, is it fair to describe that as
loving-kindness meditation?
John Vervaeke: Well, it depends what you mean.
And this is where there's controversy, so
if you think of loving-kindness as a particular
good emotional state you're going to get into,
I would argue you're confusing a method with
a goal.
So positive emotions, this is Fredrickson
and other work, they open you up, they make
you curious, they afford wondering, they allow
you to question things.
They put you into an explore mode.
But it's the exploration that's important.
What I'm actually trying to do in metta is
I'm trying to open myself up so that this
overlaps with Stoicism too, right?
So the stoics have this idea that whenever
we're going into situations, we're automatically
assuming identities and assigning identities.
I'm the professor, you're the student.
Or I'm the scientist, and you're the famous
podcaster or whatever, right?
And we're doing that.
And I'm this, and this is a tool, a water
bottle, but of course it's not that in and
of itself.
And so that co-identification process is happening
mostly mindlessly, automatically, and reactively,
and the stoics were trying to get us aware
of this.
And in metta, what you're trying to do is
get aware of what identity am I assigning
to you?
What identity am I assuming and how is that
locking down the situation and how can I open
it up in an exploratory way so that more of
your suchness, what you are beyond my assigned
categories and identities can start to shape
how I see you and who I am and starts to be
shaped by resonating with that.
And now I'm trying to see more deeply into
you.
The Buddha warns against positive emotions
just as much as he warns against negative
emotions.
Like the idea, I don't like the North American
interpretation of metta as "I want to really
feel really good about people."
I think that confuses it with Christian notions
of forgiveness and other things.
What it is is "Can I come to a place where
your identity and my identity can be born
afresh right here and right now?
And what that can do for transforming both
you and I as a real possibility."
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Thank you for that clarification.
And it makes sense that, I mean, there would
be some conflating with what you mentioned,
especially with the labeling of loving-kindness
by a lot of people in the United States, just
given the history.
John Vervaeke: Can I riff on that just one
second?
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
John Vervaeke: Because that goes towards a
fundamental misunderstanding of love.
Love is not a feeling, okay, first of all,
right?
But love is not even an emotion.
When I love somebody, that can make me angry,
jealous, sad, happy, joyous.
Love is an existential binding.
It's an existential stance.
It's a commitment to this co-identification
process and it being something by which each
of us can bring out the good and cultivate
deeper personhood for each other.
Love isn't an emotion and it isn't a feeling.
So thinking that loving-kindness is cultivating
a particular emotion is not only mistaking
the Buddhist idea, it's just misunderstanding
what love is.
Love isn't an emotion.
It isn't a feeling.
It's an existential stance of commitment to
binding your identity to the identity of something
or someone else.
Tim Ferriss: So meditation, contemplation,
I'm not sure which came next.
Paraphrasing.
John Vervaeke: Circling.
Tim Ferriss: Circling.
What would be an example of circling?
John Vervaeke: Oh, so that's where you've
got to talk to Guy Sengstock at some point.
I mean, circling is this practice, and the
best way I could describe it, and it takes
— there's a lot of exercises and skills
you have to build to do the practice well.
So I don't want people to misunderstand.
I'm just talking for simplicity, right?
I'm not giving you the full secret sauce or
something like that.
The best way to describe it is how can you
and I get into — do you know what stereoscopic
vision is?
The left and right visual fields and they
integrate so you get depth.
So I want stereoscopic mindfulness, and what
does that mean?
I want mindfulness into me and mindfulness
into you, and in a way that's affording you
to get mindfulness into you and mindfulness
into me.
And then we resonate on that.
It's a way of being.
Like I noticed that you leaned forward and
did this, what's happening in you right now
as you're doing that?
And then you tell me, and then you tell me
what you're noticing in me.
And you get this kind of accelerating, mutually
disclosing mindfulness enhancement and it's
very, very powerful practice.
And then what you can do is you can use that
training to really strengthening the listening
skill.
So you practice circling with people.
They start to pick up on this kind of — it's
interesting, Tim, what people report is they
discover a kind of intimacy they didn't know
about.
It's not sexual intimacy, it's not friendship
intimacy, but it's this other kind of intimacy.
And they say paradoxical things like this
regularly.
They say, "This new kind of intimacy, but
I've always been looking for it."
They didn't know it, but they've always been
looking for it.
It's this really — right?
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like a psychedelic experience
in some ways.
John Vervaeke: Well, I don't think that's
actually off the mark.
I've got a hypothesis.
You're doing circling with multiple people
and you're having to do this multiple switching
up perspectives and inhabiting and indwelling
of other people and letting them indwell you.
And it's getting areas of the brain to talk
to each other that normally don't talk to
each other.
Very, very similar to a psychedelic experience.
I'm not going to say when I have done psilocybin,
but there was phenomenological overlap from
my experience of that and my experience in
deep flow.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, absolutely.
John Vervaeke: And then you move people to
paraphrasing.
So they get the circling ability.
They're into that.
And then what you do is I'll say something
and you stop me after, and you have to paraphrase
back to me with using as few of my words as
possible until they agree that you —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's an interesting constraint.
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Right?
So you can't just parrot back from memory,
right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
John Vervaeke: You have to understand and
convey, and the person gives you feedback.
"No, you didn't get it."
"Yes, you did."
And you practice doing that.
Tim Ferriss: What is the intent?
John Vervaeke: The intent is —
Tim Ferriss: The objective.
John Vervaeke: The intent is to realize that
one half of communication is listening.
Tim Ferriss: Shocker.
Yeah.
Got it.
John Vervaeke: Which is easy to say, but hard.
So you slow down and you make space and you
let it impact you more deeply.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
You really have to slow down to operate within
that constraint, not using the same language.
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Exactly, exactly.
And then you move into philosophical fellowship.
It's a thing I've derived from Ran Lahav's
philosophical, contemplative companionship,
or I forget what he calls it.
He and I have emailed.
So what I'm doing is not the same, but it
was inspired by him.
So it goes something like this.
You pick a philosophical text and you prime
people into this.
We're not going to be reading this text in
order to get information from it.
We're going to be reading this text in order
to be transformed by it.
We're going use this text as a way of trying
to presence a sage.
It's almost like a secular seance, right?
You're going to presence a sage so that —
Remember we talked about earlier internalizing
the sage?
You really can't do that unless the presence
of the perspectival knowing of the sage is
available to you.
So what happens is, first of all, you read
the text very slowly and then the speaker
will pick out a phrase that he or she thinks
conveys it, and then everybody chants it in
sequence.
And they chant it and they're trying to convey
as much and also resonate with what they're
sensing other people are conveying.
So it's like jazz, and you do this and then
you move into simple speech.
Everybody is allowed to say no more than three
sentences about what is being provoked, invoked,
and evoked in their interaction with the text.
And they have to try it.
And the task is I want you to convey as much
as you possibly can in as few words as possible.
And so everybody does this, but you can't
just do it atomically.
You have to pick up on what other people have
said when you do your simple speech.
And you do that for several rounds and people
— and what happens is people are also asked
try to sense how all of these different perspectives
converge back to Spinoza or Plato or Buber
or whoever it is.
And then you're doing that and then you move
into extended speech.
Everybody's now allowed to give three or four
sentences or a bit more and open it up, and
they can even relate it to some experience
that they've had in their life.
And you can see it's — and then you move
into free speech where people just talk about
it.
And what happens is people get a sense of
the text coming alive and Spinoza being present
or Buber being present, obviously not literally,
but in this sense of there's something about
the intersection in the we space that gives
them a sense of what was the mind that generated
or as the origin of all of this, and you resonate
with it and you pick it up and it gives you
an opportunity to internalize the sage.
Tim Ferriss: I would love to try that.
Have any of those experiences been so memorable
that to this day you remember a specific phrase
from a text that helped to catalyze just an
extraordinary experience?
Are there any that you've seen really light
things on fire in an interesting way?
John Vervaeke: I think one in Spinoza was
"God is related to the world the way the mind
is related to the body."
Tim Ferriss: Ooh, can you say that one more
time?
I'll have to marinate with that one.
John Vervaeke: God is related to the world
in the same way the mind is related to the
body.
I forget where that's from.
I think it might have been from the Emendation
of the Intellect.
I'm not sure.
Tim Ferriss: I would definitely need more
time to ramp up my RPMs to begin to chew on
that, but what does that mean to you?
John Vervaeke: That phrase means he's trying
to challenge Descartes within a Cartesian
framework, which is part of the brilliance
of Spinoza.
That's why his book is called Ethics.
But he presents it as like Euclid's Elements.
He presents it as this completely logical
argument with theorems and proofs.
Tim Ferriss: So God is to the world as the
mind is to the body?
John Vervaeke: Yeah, because what he's trying
to say there, and by the way, he's not the
only person to say — I can find similar
things in Maximus the Confessor from the Orthodox
Christian tradition.
But what he's trying to say is you have to
understand that the order of causes, that's
your body, and the order of intelligibility
are actually — they have to fundamentally,
well, be in contact.
They have to conform to each other or we're
lost.
No knowledge is possible for us.
And so the mind, which is the tracking of
intelligibility, and the body, which is the
laying out of causal patterns, have to interpenetrate
and map onto each other in this profound way,
kind of like the way the software and the
hardware mesh together within a computer.
And then that is how God is related to the
universe.
God is related to the cosmos.
That God isn't some other thing.
God is the intelligibility that's non-logically
identical with the causal patterns of things.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
John Vervaeke: I don't know if that helps.
Tim Ferriss: Well, could you restate that
just for a knuckle-dragger like me?
Remember, I'm from Long Island, originally.
How do you relate to God now?
I'd be so curious to know if you use that
word at all.
If it is a word that you use, what would be
a simple way of describing to a five-year-old?
Yes, I am comparing myself to a five-year-old.
What that means to you.
John Vervaeke: I appreciate the framing.
I'm a non-theist.
And this is the idea that there are a shared
set of presuppositions of modern theism.
Ancient theism is a very different form of
theism, but modern theism and modern atheism
share presuppositions.
And they go like this, something like God
is the supreme being, the ultimate being,
the super thing.
And the best way to relate to God is by having
beliefs about him/her/it.
And that sacredness is to have true beliefs
about this super being and to govern your
life accordingly.
And the theist and the atheist both agree
to that definition.
And the theist says yes, and the atheist says
no.
And the non-theist says, "I reject all of
those presuppositions."
I don't think of ultimate reality as a thing.
I don't think of it as a being.
I think of it as the ground of being and being
is a no-thingness.
It is not a thing.
It is that in which all things come to be.
Being isn't a being.
This isn't something you can just get to —
Tim Ferriss: Very Daoist, also.
Very Daoist.
John Vervaeke: Very Daoist.
The Dao that can be spoken of is not the Dao,
and the naming is the myriad way and the emptiness
of the cup is what makes the cup function.
All of these non-thingness metaphors, it's
like water, right?
They're all trying to get you to understand
that being the ground, the really real isn't
a thing.
It's a no-thingness, which is not the same
thing as nothingness.
And that we can enter into a profound relationship
with that no-thingness.
Let me give you an analogy.
I love my partner.
She's an amazing woman, and I'm fortunate
to be with her.
I do not think I will ever completely grasp
or understand her because there is something
about her that always is transcending herself
and transcending my understanding of her.
There is something in that sense properly
mysterious about her.
Any frame I put around her, she shines into
it, but she also withdraws from it further
into the mystery that she is.
And that's why I continue to fall in love
with her, right?
And so that mystery of no-thingness is something
into which we can fall deeply in love.
We can.
The no-thingness in me.
For example, what's the no-thingness in you?
Every time you step back, remember the glasses,
and look at yourself, "There I am."
James makes this move, other people, William
James and other people.
That's the observed self, but that's never
the observing self.
The observing self can never be brought into
view.
That is not any thing that can be seen by
you.
It is that which makes any seeable thing seeable
to you, right?
There's a no-thingness in you, and that no-thingness
in you can come into deep resonance with the
no-thingness of ultimate reality such that
you fall in love with it.
And this is not about belief.
This is about deeply coupling so that it discloses
itself more and more to you as you are drawn
beyond yourself more and more.
It's like the way you fall in love with another
person.
And so you can learn to fall in love with
the depths of reality.
And it's like —
It is a source of intelligibility that is
never exhausted, but it is not itself directly
intelligible because if it is, there would
have to be a principle behind it that made
it intelligible.
It is the principle of intelligibility.
So it is not itself intelligible.
And that is precisely what makes it sacred.
I reciprocally love it, open myself up to
it.
It is an inexhaustible felt of new intelligibility,
new insight, new connectedness, new meaning.
And I think that's a proper understanding
of sacred that isn't primarily about believing
propositions.
So I'm a non-theist, and I understand God
to be a way of pointing to that.
Tim Ferriss: Great.
Very, very helpful.
And as you're talking about the sacred, and
maybe I'm already losing track of the definition
that you just provided, but I'm wondering
if Tai Chi, or let me put it in some context.
If you experience the sacred, if one of the
indicators or precursors of experiencing the
sacred is a sense of timelessness, and if
that's something that you seek or experience
in your sort of ecology practices, including
Tai Chi, I'm wondering if that factors in
somehow.
John Vervaeke: Yes, it does.
I mean, and many traditions sort of do this.
Timelessness, and that's the proper meaning
of eternity.
Eternity doesn't mean everlasting-ness.
It means not bound by time and space, like
two plus two equals four or E equals mc squared
for that matter.
Where is it?
When is it?
Those questions don't make any sense, right?
Now, that is a way of bringing you into — because
eternity is timeless, spaceless, it's no-thingness.
It doesn't have a space.
It doesn't have a spatial temporal location
like a physical thing.
Like for example, where is E equals mc squared?
Right?
It's everywhere and nowhere.
It doesn't make any sense.
So the realization of eternity, timelessness,
you aptly described it, not unending time.
That is a way of opening up to how being is
distinct from beings.
But you have to make the move.
This is Plato.
You have to ascend out of the cave, but you
also have to return back down into the cave,
which is you also have to see that being also
is and is within and includes the beings.
It's like the sacred is within everything
but not enclosed by it.
It is beyond everything but not excluded,
if that makes any sense.
So the timelessness is a move, but then you
— it's dialogical.
You come out, and then you come back and you
see the world in a grain of sand and heaven
in a wild flower.
You hold infinity in the palm of your hand
and spend eternity in an hour.
Like that, Blake, that's how you get to the
cultivation of wisdom.
Tim Ferriss: Part of the reason I asked is
that, for instance, I have friends who surf.
And they self-describe or describe their experiences
of flow as time stopping or not existing.
And they'll also say, "The ocean is my church."
I just came back from a trip where a mountain
guide said, "The mountains are my church."
And so that to me brings up the question of
whether one worthwhile pursuit would be trying
to find activities that provoke this sense
of timelessness to fill the void that was
left when religion vacated the premises for
so many people in the modern world.
I don't know if you have any thoughts on that.
John Vervaeke: I have a lot of thoughts on
that.
That's a big, big part of what went on in
Awakening from the Meaning Crisis.
I think you want to — I mean, I think there's
a continuum from insight to flow to mystical
experiences to higher states of consciousness.
And I think you want to expand your cognitive
flexibility, your cognitive competence, so
that you can experience the whole continuum
and you want to situate it within an ecology
of practices that is guarding you against
self-deceptive bullshit and all that kind
of thing.
But those flow, and awe, and profound senses
of at-one-ment or a sense of non-duality.
So I use the term for this sense of connectedness,
religio, which is one of the purported, possible
etymological roots of the word religion.
And I think what people are saying is, "I
got this profound sense of connected to myself
and to the depths of reality, when I'm in
the mountains or when I'm — the ocean."
Right?
And Aquinas called God an ocean of being.
And I'm connected to this.
Right?
And what this does is it gives me a sense
of being deeply coupled to what is deeply
real, within and without.
And I think there are ecologies of practices
that can do this for people outside of an
explicit religious framework.
Now, I would say that dismissing the religious
traditions as if there's nothing we need to
learn from them, I think that's also a mistake.
I think we should respect —
Tim Ferriss: Agreed.
John Vervaeke: — and dialogue with them
and learn as much as we can.
And I've said this before.
If people take from my work a way of how they
can return to a religious home, if they get
more out of Islam, they get more out of Buddhism,
they get more of Christianity, great.
I'm not in dispute with that.
But I also want to help afford an ecology
of practices for the nones, the N-O-N-E-Ses,
the people who say they have no official religious
affiliation, for all kinds of reasons.
I'll use the metaphor your friends gave.
Is there a way for them to find a church or
temple or mosque, by which they mean a set
of practices that gives them that profound
religio?
Yes, there is.
And this is important.
The solution to the meaning crisis and nihilism
is not to brow people with argument or legislation.
It's to enable them to fall in love with the
depths of reality within and without and between.
Again, that is what we need.
Tim Ferriss: Hmm.
Let me ask you.
This is going to maybe seem like a non-sequitur,
but I imagine you have some thoughts.
First, as bit of background, I know many religious
people all over the world, and the connective
tissue, the pattern that I think I have observed
in those who seem to be content, at peace
—
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: — is, among other things, a
strong sense of community.
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And the specific community I'd
like to ask you about are Sufis, because one
of my most fascinating acquaintances is a
— well, I don't know if he would call himself
Sufi, but he certainly studies Sufism and
is deeply immersed.
He lives in the Middle East.
What are your thoughts, observations, if any?
John Vervaeke: Yeah, so a couple of things
from my biography.
When I went to Shiatsu bootcamp, I learned
Shiatsu, as I said, and one of the people
teaching was a Sufi master, and huge impact
on me.
And my partner, her family, her father, his
father was within the Sufi tradition.
They're Persian.
And so Sufism, right, very, very profound.
And a lot of the poetry that they treat — and
I mean this as a compliment, not as a insult.
They treat the poetry religiously, Hafez and
Rumi and other people.
Right?
And a lot of it is maybe not directly Sufi,
but deeply influenced by Sufism.
Tim Ferriss: Deeply influenced.
John Vervaeke: And Corbin, who has influenced
me profoundly around the imaginal, also deeply
influenced by Sufism.
Tim Ferriss: What was that name?
John Vervaeke: Corbin.
Henry Corbin, C-O-R-B-I-N.
He's the guy that sort of coined the difference
between the imaginary and the imaginal, and
things like that.
And then, I do a practice.
One of my practices is what I call responsive
poiesis.
Poiesis is the Greek word for poetry, but
it also means "making," the way we make new
sense that we didn't have before.
And what I'll do is I'll read in a Lectio
Divina fashion, this — not reading for information
but reading for transformation.
I'll read a Sufi poem, and then I'll try and
write a poem in response.
It's not trying to parody it or parrot it
or repeat it.
I'm responding to it.
It's responsive poiesis.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it's like the paraphrasing.
It's very interesting.
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Yes.
Very, very.
But not just paraphrasing, but even more.
Like, "I've really heard you, and now this
is how I can respond to what you've said."
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
John Vervaeke: Yeah.
And so the Sufism is really important to me
in that sense.
Now, you have to be really careful.
You don't want to engage in inappropriate
cultural appropriation.
You don't want to commodify things.
You want to receive things as they're given
and in respect.
But for me, Sufism is important because it
represents, well, part of a thesis I've been
arguing for, which is Neoplatonism has this
tremendous capacity to enter into reciprocal
reconstruction with other powerful worldviews,
cultural frameworks.
It did that with Christianity.
It did that with Judaism, Kabbalah.
It does it with Islam and Sufism.
Sufism is directly — they will even talk
about Plotinus, one of the — right?
But Neoplatonism is also capable of entering
into reciprocal reconstruction with science.
It did it at the late Renaissance and helped
give birth to science, by the way.
Kepler and Galileo are deeply influenced by
Neoplatonism.
It did it at the beginning of the 20th century.
Lot of the people around the Einsteinian Revolution
are deeply influenced by Neoplatonism and
things that are somewhat similar like Vedanta
and other things like that.
So this is really powerful.
Tim Ferriss: I should've asked this earlier,
but I was planning on coming back to it.
So Neoplatonism, I — oh, I think I understand
what "neo" means, and certainly Plato, but
Neoplatonism, what is that, for those of us,
including myself, who honestly could not give
a definition?
John Vervaeke: So it's the grand unified field
theory of ancient philosophy as a way of life.
Not academic philosophy, but philosophy as
a way of life for the cultivation of wisdom
and meaning and virtue, individually and collectively.
What it does is, it integrates Socratic, Platonic
spirituality with Aristotelian ideas about
knowledge as conformity contact with stoic
principles of how to properly cultivate virtue
and metacognitive abilities.
And it integrated them all together, and not
just as some LEGO blocks being put together,
but organically.
So they all came to, I would argue, a greater
fruition within that integration.
And so it became this grand unified, powerful
living framework, so much so that when it
encounters major world religions, they typically
can't ignore it or dispense with it.
They typically enter into profound integration
with it, like in Christianity, like in Judaism,
like in Sufism, like in science.
And it looks like if Thomas Plant is right,
along the Silk Road possibly with Vedanta,
possibly with Buddhism.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so we are going to continue
this thread, but I wanted to pause to return
to the personal, if you wouldn't mind.
John Vervaeke: I don't mind.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
You'll have to the pardon maybe the way that
this question is couched, but I just read
Lonesome Dove, which is 950 or 980 pages,
and then, now I'm watching the three-part
television series with Robert Duvall and so
on, which is very good.
But I'm noticing things have to get omitted.
Many, many, many, many, many things have to
get omitted.
And so they're trying to hit the most seminal
moments from this Pulitzer Prize-winning novel
about the American West.
If one were to make a film about your search
for meaning or your creation of meaning over
your life, what would those seminal moments
be?
What would some of those milestones be?
John Vervaeke: Leaving Christianity.
Encountering Socrates.
Finding the Tai Chi, metta, Vipassana ecology
of practices.
Reading Pierre Hadot and rediscovering ancient
philosophy not as discourse but as a way of
life.
Discovering 4E cognitive science that gave
me a way of talking about wisdom and self-transcendence
and flow and embodiment that was consonant
with what I was learning from these two wisdom
traditions, the Socratic-Neoplatonic tradition
and the sort of proto-Zen, Buddhist-Taoist.
And then teaching a course at U of T called
Buddhism and Cognitive Science.
A student then coming to me after taking the
course and saying, "You should put this on
as a YouTube series."
That became Awakening from the Meaning Crisis.
Because of that, meeting people who became
very interested in these ideas about ecologies
of practices.
And we didn't do the final one, by the way.
We didn't do dialectic Into dia-logos.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
We should do that.
John Vervaeke: Well, maybe another time.
But anyways, right, and meeting people like
Guy and meeting Christopher Mastropietro.
People say this.
And again, asking for charity from the audience,
right, because this could sound ridiculously
pretentious.
But people often say if I'm Socrates, and
that's what I aspire to be at least, right,
Chris is Plato.
I totally agree with that.
The natural lyricism, the eloquence, the gift
of reflection, the authenticity, the depth.
Meeting him, getting to work with him.
Meeting, of course, my current partner.
That would be, I guess, the arc right now.
Tim Ferriss: Could you say more about, if
I'm getting the pronunciation right, Pierre
Hadot?
Is that right?
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Oh, Pierre Hadot.
When I was asked — I think it was Jonathan
Rowson.
Was it?
No, it's Jules Evans on Rebel Wisdom, the
book that changed my life.
I picked What Is Ancient Philosophy?
by Pierre Hadot.
That book, and philosophy as a way of life.
And this is where Hadot brings out that philosophy
is not primarily about the propositional.
It's not primarily about declarative discourse.
Philosophy is a way of life in which you're
training skills, states of mind, perspectives,
traits of characters, and those are all the
components of virtue.
That's what philosophy as a way of life is
about.
It's about what Hadot called spiritual exercises,
by which people entered into this process
of profound aspirational transformation for
the cultivation of virtue and the deepening
of the love of wisdom.
And this just blew me away because it represented
what I had actually saw in ancient philosophy,
but what had not been provided to me by academic
philosophy.
And so that just opened up so much for me.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So books.
You are, I think fair to say, a connoisseur
of books.
You're an avid reader.
You also have an extensive reading list on
your website.
You have the Awakening from the Meaning Crisis
book list.
If you were only allowed to choose two books
that you could personally reread from that
— it doesn't have to be exactly two.
It could be one.
It could be three.
Doesn't really matter, but you were disallowed
from ever rereading other books on the list.
You only got to choose two or three.
Which one, two, or three would you choose,
potentially?
John Vervaeke: Plato's Dialogues and Plotinus'
Ennead.
Tim Ferriss: What are the reasons for those
two?
John Vervaeke: Those books are sacred to me.
Remember I talked about sacredness as an inexhaustible,
fountain of intelligibility —
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
John Vervaeke: — this reciprocal opening
with the world?
I read Plato.
It transforms me.
I go out and see things in the world I hadn't
seen.
I live that way, and then that feeds back
into me and transforms me.
And then I read the text as a transformed
person, and I see things I hadn't seen before.
That opens me up.
I now go out into — and that just keeps
happening.
And it's been happening since I first read
The Republic, since I first read The Symposium.
I read Plotinus' Ennead on the nature of beauty
or on the nature of One and contemplation,
on dialect, any of these great Enneads.
And what's astonishing about Plotinus — and
it's Neoplatonism, so you need to be educated
in Platonism, Stoicism, Aristotelianism.
So I don't recommend people just pick up Plotinus.
Read some good secondary sources on it first.
But imagine you could read a text that was
simultaneously a profound philosophical argument
and a spiritual exercise that was transforming
you the way meditation and contemplation to,
and they were woven together with irreplaceable
artistry.
That's Plotinus.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
That should be the book blurb on the back
of the cover.
If you could only choose two poets to —
John Vervaeke: Ah.
Tim Ferriss: — nourish your soul, for lack
of a better way to phrase it — ah, could
be two to three again.
We don't need to be exact about it, but who
would make the short list for you?
John Vervaeke: Rilke is first and foremost
for me.
I won't get it perfectly, but the poem that
goes something like, "Ah, not to be cut off,
even by the slightest partition from the law
of the stars.
What is it?
What is it if not intensified sky, hurled
through with birds and filled with the winds
of homecoming?"
And it's like, "Yeah, that's what the experience
of the sacred is like."
Or you read "The Archaic Bust of Apollo,"
and he does all this thing, and you're just
drawn into this statue, and it's coming alive.
And then he suddenly breaks it and says, "You
must change your life."
That's the deep response to beauty.
That's the most appropriate response to beauty.
You must change your life.
Right?
That.
So Rilke, hands down.
The second.
The second one is a bit of a toss-up for me.
Probably Blake.
I quoted Blake a few minutes ago.
But there's Gerard Manley Hopkins and Yeats
also really, really important for me.
Tim Ferriss: Do you think it's important to
find poetry that resonates for yourself predominantly
in your native language?
John Vervaeke: No.
Rilke doesn't.
Which is —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
John Vervaeke: Because Rilke's in German.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
John Vervaeke: And of course, I did enough
German way back when in order to get my PhD,
a long time ago in a galaxy far, far away.
But yeah, I can't read German now, certainly
not the way you need to be able to read it
to pick up on poetry.
Rilke still moves me profoundly, even in translation,
so yeah.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
And funny enough, I was listening to Coltrane
jazz before this conversation, which maybe
was a good warm-up for the conversation.
And I have a new collection of translations.
I want to get the name of the author correct.
So it is a new translation of Rumi poetry.
John Vervaeke: Oh, yes.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And it is by — I'm not going
to pronounce this correctly, but Haleh Liza
Gafori.
As a Persian or Persian American, I mean,
her knowledge of the language so enriches
how she is able to convey passages that could
be real stumbling blocks for anyone who is
basing their translation off of another translation
or who is a non-native —
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: — speaker.
It's very hard to translate, period.
But it's even harder to translate poetry.
It's like, do you choose the cadence?
Do you choose to try to match the alliteration
or what the equivalent of alliteration would
be?
It's such a formidable task.
I was very impressed by the book.
I would be remiss if I didn't ask you, if
you're open to a few more questions —
John Vervaeke: I'm fine with it.
I'm enjoying this.
Let's keep going.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Wonderful.
4E.
I think this is important for us to discuss.
What are the four Es?
John Vervaeke: So I think we should have six
Es, but I'll tell you what the standard four
Es are.
Tim Ferriss: And then the bonus two, I'm into
it.
John Vervaeke: So this is the idea that cognition
is inherently embodied, first E. Embedded,
coupled to the environment, second E. Right?
Enacted, right?
Cognition is something that you are doing.
It's not something you have.
Right?
It's between you and the world, not within
you.
Right?
And then extended.
Most of our cognition is not done inside of
us.
It's done through the world.
This includes other people.
So for example, you and I are having a conversation
right now.
We're solving a problem, and this is depending
on people building computers, setting up the
Internet, setting up Zoom or Riverside.
Neither one of us invented the English language,
et cetera.
And all of these things, and even literacy.
Literacy's not natural, but we internalize
it, but it allows us to link our cognition
in profound ways.
And so most of our problem-solving is done
in extended way.
I guess the classic book by this is Cognition
In the Wild by Ed Hutchins, where he talks
about the fact that nobody, no person, navigates
a ship.
There's a whole bunch of different people
doing different roles and a whole bunch of
equipment, and they form a dynamical system
that is actually responsible for navigating
the ship.
Myself and one of my dear friends and great
co-authors, Dan Chiappe, we published three
papers on NASA scientists moving the rovers
around on Mars.
Right?
And how do they form this distributed cognition,
especially with that huge time gap, right,
the time delay, and how do they make it work?
And how does that distributed cognition work?
And because they get very powerful sense of
an emergent kind of we-agency that's above
and beyond just adding the part.
That's the extended.
So, embodied.
You don't have a body.
You are a body.
And your mind and your body are not separate
things.
They're different aspects of what you are.
And people may say, "What do you mean by that?"
What do I mean by that?
Well, remember I said earlier, you have this
problem you're facing, which is, "What do
I pay attention to?"
Right?
"What do I focus my attention to?
What do I ignore?"
And this is not cold calculation.
It's also your affect.
It means what do you care about, and what
do you not care about?
Read Montague, the neuroscientist, put it
really well.
He said, "The difference between us and computers
is we care about information, and they don't."
Right?
And that's our great strength and our great
weakness.
Now the thing is, why do you care about information?
You care about information because, and this
is the work of Evan Thompson, a colleague
of mine — well, he was at U of T. I'm still
a friend.
Right?
It is, you are a self-making thing.
That's what a living thing is.
You care about information because you are,
moment by moment, taking care of yourself.
Not that yourself is over here, and you're
taking care of it.
You are a self-organizing, self-taking-care-of
thing.
And because of that, you have to care about
this information rather than that information.
And organisms with other bodies presumably
have different salience landscapes.
Wittgenstein famously well-said, "Even if
a lion could speak, we would not understand
him."
Because even if they were using English correctly,
what they found relevant and salient would
be bizarre to us because they have different
bodies that are embedded in different environments.
And that is not happenstance.
That is constitutive of you being a cognitive
agent.
If you are not embodied, you do not have any
reason for caring about this information rather
than that information.
And then you have faced the fact that the
world is [inaudible] explosive in the amount
of information available to you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
This is, very ineptly, what I was trying to
convey very early in the conversation, predominantly
— and I encourage people to find this.
It's not going to be immediately coming to
the tip of my tongue.
But Steve Jurvetson, who's a very technical
investor, I think he did electrical engineering
and mechanical engineering degree in three
years at Stanford or something like that.
I'm probably getting some of the specifics
wrong, but he's been on the podcast before.
And he had this very long Facebook post discussing
why it would be difficult, if not impossible,
to experience anything as a human if we were
just brains in a jar.
John Vervaeke: Yes.
Brains in a vat problem.
Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Brain in a vat problem.
And I found it very compelling and sort of
embarrassing that it wasn't self-evident to
me right off the bat.
It's like without these appendages and this
multifaceted organism to interface with an
environment, what we experience as consciousness
just doesn't seem, at least offhand to me,
possible, which makes it very precious that
we have this experience.
John Vervaeke: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And in —
John Vervaeke: Being embodied is really wonderful,
actually.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
So what are the two Es that lead to six?
John Vervaeke: Emotional.
The idea that our knowing and our emoting
are separable things, I think is one of the
great mistakes that came out of the Enlightenment
Romanticism conflict.
Being rational, ratio, proper proportioning.
It's about putting things into perspective,
perspectival knowing, and caring about them
in the right way, and knowing within that,
when and where and how to be logical, et cetera,
et cetera.
We've already talked about that.
And I mean, a good place to point people about
this is Damásio's Descartes' Error.
Right?
You have people who have a certain kind of
brain damage.
The frontal cortex is working such that you
could give them a standard IQ test, and they
could do all the computations quite well in
it, but you could drive them insane by saying,
"Before you take the test, I want you to choose.
Should you write it in red ink or black ink
or blue ink?"
And then they go crazy because they have no
motivation.
They have no affect.
They have no reason to care about this rather
than that.
Right?
Emotion and cognition are interweaving and
inter-affording.
So that's why emotion should be the next E.
Emotions are not irrational.
Right?
Like I said, there is no one faculty that
is infallibly good.
Right?
Yes, your emotions can lead you astray, but
try living without them and see how rational
you can be.
Right?
Your agency will be crippled.
And I mean that seriously.
Right?
So that would be my fifth E.
The sixth has to do with a somewhat technical
term, exaptation, which is drawn from evolutionary
theory.
Let me give you a clear example.
So I'm using my tongue to speak, right?
But tongues did not evolve for speech.
If they did, all the animals with tongues
would be talking to us.
Right?
What you have is you have a very flexible
muscle, right, because it's for mastication,
and it has a lot of very fine nerve endings
because it's for poison and sucrose detection
and things like that.
And it happens to be in the air passageway.
So you've got something that's preadapted,
already almost perfectly built for being a
speaking machine.
And so exaptation is you take something, and
you repurpose it.
And this is the work of Michael Anderson.
Like the way that cerebellum has been repurposed
from being a sensory motor balance thing to
being how we balance and move around in abstract
space.
And so that exaptation, the idea of Michael
Anderson, more recent work, especially in
[inaudible] and others, is the brain is constantly
doing that.
The brain is constantly exapting things, like
machines, that have been built for doing one
thing, and then they get repurposed.
Or they also use the language of circuit reuse,
like from computer science, right, that has
been repurposed.
Tim Ferriss: I like the six Es.
I'm being very careful with my language here,
so I'll try not to be, because it'll end up
being too clunky if I self-edit too intensely.
Do you have any heretical beliefs about consciousness
that people in the space would strongly disagree
with or think are unfounded, yet you have
some degree of conviction in?
John Vervaeke: Yes.
And if people are interested in this, I have
a more long form presentation of a talk I
gave in Thunder Bay at the Conference on Consciousness
and Conscience.
And I talk about the three questions of consciousness.
And so the first question is the question
everybody's really fixated on, which is the
nature question, which is, something that
seems so non-physical, how does it possibly
exist in the otherwise physical universe?
And that's the nature question.
And of course, you have Chalmers' version
of the hard problem and qualia and things
like that.
And I'll come back to qualia in a second.
Now there's another question which is as equally
important, and people don't give it enough
attention, and they should.
And this is the function question, which is,
what is consciousness for?
What does it do?
And before you give me an answer, let me try
and make this more problematic to you.
You do a lot of very, very sophisticated stuff
without consciousness.
You are taking the noises coming out of my
face hole and translating them into ideas
in your mind.
And you have no idea how that process works.
You have no introspective access to it, right?
I make noises.
You have ideas.
What's happening in between?
Don't know.
Or think about the complex, sophisticated
action you can do, how little attention you
have to bring to walking or even, and you've
had this, I have no doubt, probably, highway
hypnotism, where you've been driving and you
realize "For the past 15, I haven't been paying
attention to the road at all.
And yet this sort of zombie inside me has
been managing to keep me on the road.
And I wouldn't rely on it or anything," but
you did.
So the question is, our unconscious seems
to be so powerful.
Why do we have consciousness?
What's it do?
And why do we love it so much?
And then the third question is the meta question.
What's the relationship between these questions?
So here's my first heresy.
Unlike many people, I think these two questions
have to be answered in a completely integrated
fashion.
I think trying to answer the nature question
without answering the function question is
doomed to fail.
And I think trying to answer the function
question without trying to answer the nature
question is doomed to fail.
So there's the first Vervaeken heresy, and
I don't know who's going to be Devil's advocate
for me.
But anyways, oh no, that'd be the opposite.
That would be my person putting me on trial.
So that's the first.
Here's the second.
The second is, we can do this.
We can find a way of answering this if we
pay attention to a convergence that is occurring
about what is the function of consciousness?
And then I think this gives us a lot of the
machinery for explaining a lot of the qualia
that are so central to the nature of consciousness.
Tim Ferriss: Qualia being?
John Vervaeke: What is that?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
John Vervaeke: Qualia means the subjective
feel, the redness of red to you.
You're not just unconsciously reacting to
wavelengths.
You're having this experience of redness.
That's a qualia.
And that seems to be something in consciousness,
and it's subjective in nature.
And we don't even know if your qualia and
my qualia are the same.
Tim Ferriss: Well, very often they're not.
I mean, Japan is a good example of that.
Their green and blue are not the same green
and blue that we see, depending on the crosswalk
go signals and so on.
John Vervaeke: And even a person who's color
blind has different qualia.
Or as Thomas Nagel famously argued, bats who
use echolocation have qualia that we don't
have.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Right.
John Vervaeke: Okay.
So that's what that means.
And that's the hard problem, because there
doesn't seem to be any way of explaining their
nature.
And this is work I'm doing with a whole bunch
of other people, so I don't want to take sole
credit.
But I think if you make use of functionality
and you make use of the four kinds of knowing
and things like this, I think you can give
an integrated answer.
There is a consensus emerging, and I've published
on this and talked about this, around what
consciousness does, what's it for.
And then I think once you get that and you
open up that functionality, you actually get
a phenomenology, you get an explanation of
the experience out of that.
So the converging thing is that, what consciousness
is for and it overlaps with attention and
working memory and fluid intelligence.
Think about when you're driving on the highway,
when do you come back to it?
If something unexpected happens, or there's
a really complex situation suddenly emerging,
or there's an ill-defined problem that you're
not quite sure how to formulate and frame,
that's what you need consciousness for.
So what is consciousness?
It's this higher order relevance realization.
It's about re-realizing what's relevant and
important so that you can deal with the added
challenge of zeroing in on relevant information
that is given to you by novelty, complexity,
and ill-defined-ness.
That's what consciousness is for.
It's enhanced relevance realization.
And that's why it overlaps with working memory
and things like that.
Tim Ferriss: Now, that does sound like a consciousness
that would extend to animals other than humans.
John Vervaeke: Totally.
It helps to explain our intuition about this.
Generally, when people are willing to extend
the attribution of consciousness, they actually
do it in a way, without realizing, that tracks
how much fluid intelligence do they think
that organism has?
Because fluid intelligence, working memory,
attention, all of these things are about relevance
realization and enhancing it.
And so you've got this consensus.
Okay, now let's say we get relevance realization,
and that consciousness of higher order version.
What about qualia?
Well, first of all, let's divide qualia, and
this is the second Vervaeke heresy.
Let's divide qualia into two kinds of qualia.
There's the typical qualia that philosophers
love to talk about, the adjectival qualia,
like blueness and greenness and sweetness.
But there are adverbial qualia, there are
qualias of here-ness, now-ness, togetherness
of my experience.
I'm here, I'm now, my experience is together.
There's a unity and a here now presencing
of consciousness.
The adverbial.
Now here's the thing, talk to people who have
engaged in long-term meditative practice.
And this is well documented, read Foreman
for the documentation, I've been here in this
state.
And you get into a state called the pure consciousness
event.
You're not conscious of anything.
You're definitely not conscious of any qualia,
you're not conscious of any thought, you're
not even conscious of consciousness.
You're just conscious.
You don't black out.
All you have is a pure perspectival, participatory
knowing of consciousness.
You're conscious by being conscious, and there's
nothing else going on.
Now what's interesting about that is you don't
black out because you can remember being there
in that state.
There's no adjectival qualia, but consciousness
is still present.
So think about that for a second.
But what doesn't go away?
You don't lose the here-ness because people
say, in the pure consciousness event, there's
full presence.
You don't lose now-ness.
They talk about, "I'm in eternity."
This pure now-ness.
And they don't lose togetherness.
They talk about pure oneness and unity.
The adverbial qualia are on steroids and the
adjectival qualia have gone away.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's interesting.
It's a good way to put it.
John Vervaeke: Which means the adjectival
qualia are not necessary.
And there's other arguments.
They're not sufficient for consciousness.
Consciousness is primarily about adverbial
qualia.
And adverbial qualia can be explained by relevance
realization.
It's how are things relevant to you?
That gives you the centeredness to consciousness.
The timing of things is an important part
of relevance.
How things belong together, fit together.
Relevance realization gives you the adverbial
qualia.
So if you understand the functionality of
consciousness as heightening relevance realization,
it will be present in all of those adverbial
qualia.
And there will be a sense of those even being
heightened when you're in a pure consciousness
state.
That's the third and last Vervaeke heresy.
So it's a completely naturalistic explanation
of consciousness.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
I've got a number of follow-up questions here.
I need to set the table a little bit.
So I was overseas, and ended up in conversation
with two very smart Russian emigres who had
a lot of biophysics background and exposure.
And we were having a lot of coffee, or I was
having a lot of coffee.
Well, at least one of them were only drinking
tea.
Nonetheless, ended up talking about, and by
talking, I mean me listening to them talk,
about quantum effects in the brain.
It was well above my pay grade, but it led
me to really want to have someone on the podcast,
at some point, who can credibly speak, because
there are a lot of whack-a-doodles into all
sorts of new age stuff who would love to try
to talk about this, but someone who has credible,
scientific bonafides that would allow them
to talk about this.
And this leads to my question, which hopefully
doesn't get me too many heckles from the audience.
It probably will get a few.
Do you have any thoughts on panpsychism?
Is it just nonsense, in your view?
Is there plausibly something to it?
There seem to be very strong feelings on many
sides related to this.
Do you have any thoughts or opinions on the
matter?
John Vervaeke: Yeah.
The quantum thing, the best people, I think,
would be Penrose or Hameroff, people like
that.
I think it's undeniable.
We have empirical evidence that there's quantum
stuff going on in smell.
I think that's undeniable.
Is there quantum stuff going on in the kind
of consciousness that is overlapping with
attention and working memory and intelligence?
No.
Because you show all kinds of limitations
that are clear evidence that you are operating
like a classical machine, like all the biases
I talked about and all the ways you ignore
all kinds of information, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
And you also have problems about temperature.
I think those people give the best representation.
I'm giving you why I'm not convinced by that.
I think the evidence against it is significantly
greater than any evidence for it.
And like you, I don't like the argument that
goes consciousness is weird, quantum is weird,
therefore consciousness is quantum.
That's just ridiculous.
Now, panpsychism is a different thing.
And you don't have to be convinced about quantum
stuff to be a panpsychist.
Tim Ferriss: And I should have defined my
terms, but would you mind just giving people
an overview of what panpsychism is?
John Vervaeke: So panpsychism is a version
of what's called, well, I would argue, it's
a version of what's called elemental property
dualism.
And so the idea here is, we have fundamental
building blocks of our ontology, space, time,
force, matter, energy.
And we may move those around, but that that's
not important right now.
And we don't try and explain them.
We use them to explain other things because
they're fundamental.
And like I say, physics, some people are arguing,
we may reject time and space as fundamental
and move to something deeper.
I don't know.
But that's not relevant to the core of the
argument.
The core of the argument is that consciousness
is like that.
Consciousness is a fundamental, ontological
building block, and therefore the attempt
to explain it with any of the other fundamental
building blocks is impossible.
You can't do it because they are at the same
ontological, ontology, meaning the structure
of reality.
They're at the same ontological level.
They're the basement level in terms of which
you explain everything else.
So the attempt to try and explain them is
a misframing of the kind of thing they are.
And so that means if consciousness is such
a fundamental ontological building block like
space, time, energy, force, and energy and
matter are convertible, Einstein, there is
no part of reality, even empty space has got
all of these fundamental ontological building
blocks.
And if consciousness is such a fundamental
building block, it is also showing up in everything.
So my table has consciousness, not my full-blown
consciousness, but it has what it's like to
be a table.
Like, my consciousness is about perspectival
knowing.
And so, it has what's like to be a table,
it has an inner subjective experiential aspect.
Now not full-blown like mine.
Nobody's ridiculous in claiming there's some
sort of consciousness like mine somehow trapped
in this table, unable to speak or something.
We have no evidence for that.
But the idea is that there are aspects of
what it is to be a table that are what it's
like to be a table for the table and not for
me or for you.
And that would be what the claim of panpsychism
is.
The person who best makes it plausible, to
my mind, well, not necessarily agreeing, is
a colleague of mine, Bill Seager.
He's made a very strong case for the plausibility
of panpsychism.
Now, I reject panpsychism, although I accept
things that come close to it in some important
ways.
Tim Ferriss: What do you reject and what do
you accept?
John Vervaeke: I don't think that there's
anything like perspectival knowing going on
at the level of the table.
But I'm confident enough about my ignorance
of consciousness and reality to not say I'm
sure and slam on the table.
I do think, and this is work of Evan Thompson
and others in 4E cogsci, and Michael Levin,
I think there's a deep continuity.
Meaning, the principles of consciousness have
a deep continuity with the principles of cognition,
which have a deep continuity with the principles
of life, which have a deep continuity with
the principles of self-organization, which
have a deep continuity with some of the fundamental
ways in which reality unfolds for us.
And so, they're not identical.
You can't simply reduce the upper level to
the lower levels, but there are shared principles
all the way through.
And I think the evidence for a deep continuity
hypothesis is very good, and the arguments
are very important.
So I do think, for example, it's proper to
say that there's a rudimentary cognition for
a perimysium.
It's a cognitive agent, it's detecting the
sugar molecule as food, and this other molecule
as poison.
It's a little bit of an aspect, a little bit
of a perspective, and it allows it to care
about this rather than that.
Now, is that what you and I have?
No, something like that.
Does that extend below living things?
I don't think so, because self-organizing
things like the fire don't seem to direct
their behavior to preserve their own existence
the way living things do.
And I think that's a fundamental difference
in how things are organized and how they function.
So I don't think consciousness and cognition
or agency drop below the level of living things.
Tim Ferriss: This is not directly related,
but I'm curious.
You were mentioning the intimacy, the, let's
call it atypical intimacy that nonetheless
seems, I'm paraphrasing, familiar to those
who are doing circling.
And I'm wondering what are some of the most
unusual modes of cognition or relating or
perceiving that you have noticed in those
types of exercises?
John Vervaeke: In circling and philosophical
fellowship and dialectic into dia-logos?
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
John Vervaeke: All of these.
First of all, especially when you take people
through this and they start doing a lot of
that whole ecology into dialectic into dia-logos,
they will discover a nestings of intimacies.
They will discover first interpersonal intimacy
between you and I. And then they'll discover
intimacy between all of us and what is called
the we space, this emergent sort of dynamical
system that is sort of linking us and coupling
us all together.
People will start to get a sense of intimacy
to the we space, Chris and I call it the logos,
or a German word, the geist.
And then there's a third intimacy that people
sometimes get to, which is, they start to
get an intimacy through the interpersonal
and through the intimacy with the we space
to sort of like the ground, the origin, the
fount of intelligibility.
They get a sense of intimacy that we talked
about earlier as a sense of the sacred.
And what's really interesting about this is,
people from all kinds of backgrounds, resolutely
secular, will start to use spiritual and religious
language to talk about these kinds of intimacies.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's a curious, I think,
indicator.
It's like, when secular language fails, where
do you go?
Uh-oh.
What are you going to do?
You, as I understand it, had an office, I
believe, directly across the hall or close
to Dr. Jordan Peterson.
And my question is, with respect to the finding
or creation of meaning, or meaning, broadly
speaking, where would you say the two of you
most strongly agree, and where do you most
strongly disagree?
John Vervaeke: Way before Jordan became a
god, Jordan and I, we used to regularly show
up at conferences.
We shared students a lot.
We had some public debates, meaning the proper,
good sense.
And so Jordan shares with me this idea of
relevance realization as a core problem to
be explained and understood.
And the relevance realization gives us that
sense of religio, that sense of connectedness
because it's how we're coupled non-propositionally
to the world.
We've already talked about this.
Jordan and I share that a lot.
And he's very, very interested, and often
supportive of the work I do.
I'm relevance realization, intelligence, consciousness,
meaning, and the cultivation of wisdom.
And so that's where we have some very significant
agreements.
He places more emphasis on the narrative.
On narrative than I do.
I think narrative is very important.
I want to make that very clear.
I don't think we become temporally extended
moral agents without narrative.
But I think narrative depends on pre-narrative
dialogical capacities, and we can move post
narrative, because this is what many people
in wisdom traditions, mystical traditions
report, they move post narrative.
And you see techniques for getting people
to go post narrative.
Think about the Zen koan, it's designed to
get you into a narrative and then break narrative
apart.
Or Jesus of Nazareth's parables, they sound
like stories and there's a narrative.
And you read the prodigal son, and then, who
am I supposed to identify with?
Who's right?
Is it the father?
Is it the prodigal son?
And you realize, if you settle on any one
of those, you haven't got it.
And it blows the narrative apart.
And sorry if this sounds pretentious, I mean
it respectfully.
Jesus is a master of saying these things that
sort of blow people apart, blow the narrative
apart.
And we have done this publicly, he and I had
a discussion with Jonathan Pageau, and I was
challenging Jonathan and Jordan about the
emphasis on the narrative.
And that, of course, comes from Jordan, from
his Jungian background, and from Jonathan,
from his Eastern Orthodox.
Although Jonathan, to give him due credit,
came around later and he released a video
where he said, "John's right.
The nomological is not reducible to the narrative.
There's ways in which we connect to reality
that are non-narrative and are important."
And I thought that was really good of him.
So that'd be one area where Jordan and I disagree.
Tim Ferriss: Do you have to get the narrative
before you can go post narrative?
John Vervaeke: I think so.
And this is where I think the difference is.
I think that narrative is indispensable, but
I do not think that means it's metaphysically
necessary.
Let me give you an analogy.
My only language that I'm fluent in is English.
English is indispensable to me being a cognitive
agent and communicating, but I wouldn't claim
it is metaphysically necessary that every
cognitive agent speak in English and only
in English or has to know English.
That's ridiculous.
So you have to make a distinction between
indispensability.
And I think narrative is developmentally indispensable,
but I don't think it's metaphysically necessary
to the full development of our cognition.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so you have that disagreement.
You have different weighting of narrative
and not the alternative, but then the term
that you mentioned, your colleague used —
John Vervaeke: The nomological, having to
do with the lawlike structures for reality.
Tim Ferriss: There we go.
John Vervaeke: Laws and theories are powerful
and important in a way that's not reducible
to narratives.
And that's one area.
And then another area is, I put a lot more
emphasis on practices and theorizing and helping
to engineer practices and ecology of practices
than Jordan does.
That's another major difference.
Tim Ferriss: Why do you think that is?
What would his response to that be, would
you imagine?
John Vervaeke: Part of it, I think, in fairness
to him, is background.
And part of it has to do, I think, with, Jordan
is a very complex person.
I respect Jordan, I consider him a colleague
and I consider him a friend.
And what I want to say very clearly, and I
do this to his face, by the way, and because
I do it respectfully and dialogically, Jordan
is fine with this.
We disagree about things.
For example, I think postmodernism and Derrida
and Foucault, there's a lot to be learned
there.
I have criticisms of them, but there are important
arguments that need to be engaged with.
I have argued this with Jordan to his face,
he disagrees.
He thinks that postmodernism is largely crypto-Marxism,
et cetera, et cetera.
And he rejects it sort of to core.
I'm not denying that postmodernism has been
taken by people in this way, but I would also
say that many people invoke Derrida and Foucault.
They've not actually read Derrida and Foucault.
Derrida is very interested in Neoplatonism.
And Foucault was very interested in Hadot
and Stoicism towards the end of his career.
And there's reasons for that.
So I think you have to have a much more nuanced
understanding of postmodernism.
Now, I've made that argument to Jordan and
we disagree about it.
But because I respect him, and we enter into
genuine dialogue, that's fine.
Now, the problem is, Jordan also has this
other side where, and he doesn't do this with
me, where he's very confrontational, and he
admits this, and he gets very polemical, and
it's usually in the political domain.
And that's an area when he and I don't agree
very much.
But, to his credit, Jordan respects that he
and I can have significant different political
commitments and nevertheless get into deep
and important discussions of philosophical
and scientific merit.
I have to say that because I'm really tired
of people saying that because I talk to Jordan
and because I maintain the relationship that
pre-existed his godhood that I am somehow
advising or advocating for everything he says.
That's ridiculous.
I directly criticize him about a lot of things.
It's just I think it should be done in the
way that we do it and we've always done it.
And so that's a hard thing.
My relationship to him is a challenge for
me.
I've considered both options.
I've considered sort of just sort of throwing
in, and I'm part of the Petersonian camp.
And it's like, no, I can't do that.
I can't do that, in all honesty.
I disagree with Jordan about politics as the
main area.
I disagree for philosophical reasons with
Jordan about politics being the main area
in which we can solve the meaning crisis.
Politics is at the propositional level, and
is at the adversarial level.
We need the non-propositional.
That's the main place where the meaning crisis
is going to be addressed, I would argue.
I disagree with him about that.
I disagreed with him about particular philosophical
stances, like his stance on postmodernism,
et cetera.
And so, completely identifying him would be
inauthentic.
Completely rejecting him would be inauthentic.
We share a lot of concerns.
I admire many of his ideas.
I think he's done good work, published work.
He continues to make good arguments.
He's an insightful person.
And I have an ongoing history with him.
And he talks to people that I talk to.
So I'm damned if I do, damned if I don't.
So I sort of just say, well, okay, what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to show up and
interact with him as philosophically and scientifically
honestly as I can.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I had Jordan on this podcast,
and it was incredible to see how strongly
binary, not just the responses —
John Vervaeke: He's a polarizing guy.
Tim Ferriss: But also the expectations of
me were all in.
Are you all in or are you all out?
And there was part of me that wanted to say,
this is the kind of identity politics morass
that we have as such an issue.
To have any kind of reconciliation and civil
debate, it can't be, well, I'm making a strong
statement, but it shouldn't have to be that
black or white.
I think there are many areas —
John Vervaeke: I want to strengthen your argument
for you.
I want to strengthen your argument for you.
Tim Ferriss: Please, I need someone to do
this with me more regularly.
John Vervaeke: This has to do with adaptivity.
This has to do with intelligence.
Let's just give you an example of relevance
realization right here right now you have
two attentional systems, probably more, but
at least these two.
You have the task focus that is trying to
keep you focused on, what is John saying with
his multisyllabic complex sentences?
And then there's a part of you, the default
network that's mind wandering.
And I'm not accusing you of anything.
It's drifting away, it's thinking about other
things, and they're locked together.
Like evolution, the mind wandering introduces
variation.
The task network kills most of it off, but
some of it survives and helps reproduce the
conversation and keep it going.
Opponent processing, your autonomic nervous
system about arousal is biased to arousing
you.
Parasympathetic is biased to getting you to
calm down, and they're locked together in
opponent processing.
You find this all through adaptive systems.
Opponent processing.
Democracy.
I argued this when I gave a talk at the international
symposium on democracy in Prague in September.
Democracy should be opponent processing.
The best way for me to correct my perspectival
bias is to have you be in opponent processing
with me.
You take a different bias, but we agree that
we are each other's best means of self-correction.
That's how democracy should work.
And we have degenerated it into adversarial,
the other side is evil and must be destroyed
because we are perfectly right and correct
with a sinful, and I use that word advisedly,
a sinful self-righteousness on both sides.
A pox on both of your houses, I would say
to that, because you're undermining the very
opponent processing that is necessary for
democracy to be a good means for us to use
extended cognition to solve our complex problems.
So that's how I'm strengthening your argument.
Tim Ferriss: That's what I meant to say.
So thank you.
John Vervaeke: It goes something I said earlier,
stop trying to demonize or deify any one of
your faculties.
Stop trying to demonize or deify Jordan.
Confront his arguments, argument by argument.
Some of them are good, some of them are bad.
Even some of his bad arguments need to be
taken seriously because they're well-made
and they contain insight.
Some of the things you reject, but reject
it because of the content of the argument,
not because of the side you're on.
What is that accomplishing?
That is not accomplishing any overcoming of
your or my self-deception.
All it's doing is reinforcing whatever confirmation
bias we are already enslaved to.
Tim Ferriss: Talking about opponent processing
makes me think about some of my close friendships
and how I choose to develop friendships with
people who can help with the checks and balances
and the constructive pushback when helpful.
And that leads me to want to ask you, and
this is very self-interested of me, but it's
something that's on my mind a lot because
most of my friends are non-religious, but
looking to create meaning or find meaning,
as we all are.
How would you advise, say, a group of middle-aged
friends to support one another in having more
meaningful lives or creating meaning?
What can people do in a small cohort?
Would you have any recommendations?
John Vervaeke: Don't just swap beliefs.
That's insufficient.
That's just the propositional.
Commit to taking up together a living ecology
of practices.
Commit to doing that together and bring that
opponent processing into the non-propositional
aspects of your cognition, into the extended
aspects of your cognition.
Learn how to do some of these practices I've
been talking about.
Take them up together and take up ones that
involve you practicing together.
Because a big part of what the church and
the temple and the mosque did was exactly
that.
They provided a home, a tradition in which
ecologies of practices were properly homed
and supported so that people could come together
and not just communicate, but commune together
by sharing participation, I'm emphasizing
all these words because of all the ways we've
talked about them, in shared ecologies of
practices that they mutually conform to and
transform themselves to, and thereby, mutually
set up a space where they can afford each
other's transformations, where you can cultivate
together enhanced religio, enhanced sense
of sacredness, enhanced sense of the depths
within you, calling to the depths of others
and calling to the depths of reality.
Don't tell me what you believe, tell me what
you practice.
Tell me how you're practicing together and
how you're acting as checks and balances and
opponent processing on the creation and the
running of these ecologies of practices.
And commit to it the way you commit to a friendship.
Your friend is a complex, dynamical system.
An ecology of practice is a complex dynamical
system.
It takes a time and effort and commitment
and a willingness to transform and fail and
learn from mistakes in order to make this
work.
Get into an ecology of practice.
Try to make sure that that ecology of practice
is in ongoing dialogue and discussion with
the best cognitive science out there right
now, so you don't go off in weird rabbit holes
that can happen when people do this, so that
you stay tied to the best science we have
about how cognition and consciousness and
intelligence and distributed cognition and
flow, et cetera, work.
That is the single most important thing.
Now I've offered lots.
I have a full meditation course and contemplation
course, cultivation of wisdom course.
I have the whole After Socrates.
There's lots out there.
And you don't have to just pay attention to
me.
You can pay attention to the ecologies of
practices like Rafe Kelley.
I went to Return to the Source last summer,
blew me apart.
Just an amazing ecology of practices.
I've been doing a lot of participant observation
and experiment in other people's ecologies
of practices.
You have to become a connoisseur and a creator
of ecologies of practices.
There's no other way to enhance the capacity
for participating in meaning.
That would be the most central advice I would
give somebody.
Tim Ferriss: I was meaning, and I will now
ask about After Socrates.
So you have this very popular YouTube series,
Awakening from the Meaning Crisis.
Why create After Socrates?
John Vervaeke: I listened to the criticism
of other people.
Awakening from the Meaning Crisis has a couple
of main criticisms that people made.
One was, a lot of people asked at the end,
"But what do I do now?
What do I do now?
You've convinced me about the meaning crisis
and this problem, and blah blah.
But what do I do now?"
And then secondly, "You did this totally individualistically,
but how does this work with other people?"
So After Socrates is not extensive, it's intensive,
it's trying to trace the entire tradition
from Socrates, and spending a lot of time
there.
Reverse engineer.
I'm not claiming this is exactly what Socrates
did, who could claim that?
I'm trying to reverse engineer as best I can
this dialectic into dia-logos, these kinds
of practices we've been talking about, so
that people can undertake a pedagogical program.
So Tim, every episode I give an argument,
and they build on each other, like Awakening
from the Meaning Crisis.
But I also give points of reflection that
are designed to be taken up in discussion
by groups.
And then I give instruction in a particular
practice that resonates with the content of
the lecture.
So as the lecture builds the argument, intergroup
discussion is being built and a pedagogical
program is being built so that you can come
to take up the Socratic way of life in community
with other people who are taking it up and
cultivating an extended and developed ecology
of practices.
That's what After Socrates is all about.
Tim Ferriss: Where can people find After Socrates?
Where's the best place for people if they
want to learn more?
John Vervaeke: Just go on my YouTube channel.
It's right there for free.
Tim Ferriss: All right, we will certainly
link to the YouTube channel, the website,
JohnVervaeke.com.
On Twitter, @vervaeke_john.
John, this has been such a pleasure.
I've really enjoyed this conversation.
Thank you for taking so much time and being
so patient with my questions.
Hopefully it wasn't too torturous.
I do appreciate it.
John Vervaeke: You had it all.
I really enjoyed it so much so that I'll answer
your question.
If you want me ever to come back, I'd be very
happy to do so.
Tim Ferriss: I would love to do it?
I would love to do a round two.
Is there anything else you would like to say?
Any closing comments, any requests you'd like
to make of my audience?
Anything at all that you'd like to add before
we wind to a close?
John Vervaeke: I don't think so.
I would ask people to consider the two series,
Awakening from the Meaning Crisis, After Socrates.
Take a look at some of the conversations I'm
having with other people.
Try to give me the benefit of the doubt when
I'm talking to people you might not like.
Tim Ferriss: Good advice.
John Vervaeke: I guess that's all I would
have to say right now.
And again, I was a little intimidated, and
I'm not usually thinking about talking to
you.
You have quite a powerful, like I said before
we turned the recording on, reputation.
And yet you were so welcoming and accommodating.
You and I, I think, got into a mutual flow
state quite a few times.
I think it was really wonderful.
So thank you very much.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, thank you, John.
Thank you for being such a great jazz player
on the stage.
And I really, really enjoyed it.
I took tons of notes, so I have quite a lot
of reading and investigating and practicing
ahead of me.
And to everybody listening, as per usual,
we have links to everything.
I may need to do some work on my spelling
of various names, but we'll figure it out,
in the show notes at tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, please be just a bit
kinder than is necessary.
That includes to yourself, but certainly to
other people.
And remember, it's not just what you believe.
It is what you practice.
So get to practicing, folks.
And as always, thanks for tuning in.
John Vervaeke: Thank you, everyone.
[sound effect]
Tim Ferriss: I thought we would start with
a sandbox that I like to play in, and I think
you are a black belt where I am still a middling
white belt, and that's a discussion of language
and words.
And specifically, I was hoping you could perhaps
give us some examples of words that we use
commonly that frame the way we think about
life or relate to life in the West, if that
is perhaps a container that works for the
question.
John Vervaeke: Yeah, I think it is a good
container.
I think there are words that are signposts,
benchmarks for a kind of cultural cognitive
grammar, giving us some sort of our basic
conceptual vocabulary.
Two that come to mind very readily are these
two terms, subjective and objective, and people
of course forget the original meanings of
these words, but what we do is we have taken
them to be an exhaustive division of reality.
There's the interior subjective mind stuff
and there's the exterior objective physical
stuff, and we take it that that's just the
way it is and that's how we've always thought.
And that's how everybody has always thought
about reality, and that's not true.
The Greeks didn't have that division, and
of course, many Eastern philosophies don't
have that division.
And there's been critiques of that framework
which we got from Descartes, the Cartesian
framework for both the last 200 years, even
in the history of Western philosophy.
The fact that we have these terms, we bandy
them about, we think that that's all there
is.
It's complete and exhaustive and they're divided
and they're really radically incommensurable
with each other.
It just shows how well this has insinuated
itself into the very way we see ourselves,
see the world, experience ourselves.
It's very powerful and very interesting.
Part of my work is to try to undermine that
dichotomy and try and get us to think more
profoundly about that there must be something
deeper than the subjective and objective that
fundamentally makes it possible for them to
be related together.
Because if not, we are really doomed in a
kind of radical skepticism and solipsism.
Solipsism is the idea that the only thing
that's really real is your own mind kind of
thing.
So that would be one clear example.
Another one along those lines that we haven't
paid attention to how much it's changed is
the word matter.
We now take matter as actual stuff, but if
you go before the scientific revolution, matter
in the Aristotelian framework means exactly
the opposite.
It means pure potentiality, that which is
awaiting to be informed and actualized.
Aristotle's notion is a piece of wood is potentially
a chair or a table, and what makes it act,
actuality, what makes it act like a table
is its form, its structure and functional
organization.
What makes it act like a chair is its form,
but before that it's just a potential chair
or a potential table.
And that's what matter was.
It was sort of this pure potential.
And so the word has actually flipped in meaning
radically.
Then we of course think that it's always been
this way and we forgot that there's a dramatically
opposite possibility even within our own history.
So that would be too easy.
Well, not easy to reflect upon, but easy to
bring up examples of words that are very powerful
in our culture, but so much so that we see
so much by means of them that they're almost
completely transparent to us.
Tim Ferriss: How has your relating to, and
I apologize if the wording on this is clumsy,
but your relating to your experienced reality
changed as you've studied cognitive science
and philosophy and these different labels
and frameworks that despite our perhaps underlying
subconscious belief that it has always been
this way.
In the case of say, subjective, objective,
how has your own relating to life's experience
changed?
John Vervaeke: I coined a term “the transjective”
to mean that which binds the two together,
that which binds the inner life of the organism
to the outer world of the environment kind
of thing.
There I was influenced by a teacher of mine,
John Kennedy, who is a protege of J.J.
Gibson.
And so let me give you an example.
I've become aware of things.
So Gibson had a notion of an affordance.
Like so, this water bottle is graspable.
Now, the graspability isn't in my hand, I
can't grasp anything.
I can't grasp Africa or something like that.
The graspability isn't in the bottle because
like an ant can't grasp it and et cetera.
It's actual, a real relation of fittedness
between my hand and this, and the floor is
walkable by me.
And so this way of experiencing this connectedness
as a more profound way of experiencing my
mental life has now become increasingly prominent
and salient for me.
It goes towards the main work I do on scientific
work, about relevance realization and things
like that.
But it also overlaps.
I do Daoist practices.
I do Tai Chi Chuan and Qigong and things.
And that sense of connectedness that is talked
about, that shift helps me get into that sense
of connectedness in a more profound and transformative
way.
So, nobody's ever asked me that question.
That's a really good question.
It has really changed the configurations of
my experience.
What is foregrounded?
What becomes salient to me?
What such that I can actually taste it more
in my experience and be transformed more by
it?
Yes, very much so.
That's a very clear example.
And that, sorry, I'll stop in a sec, but the
way that this —
Tim Ferriss: — you can go as long as you
like.
John Vervaeke: Well, that translates in that
really — how do I say this without sounding
like a Hallmark card?
But you move to an understanding of love as
this connectedness, but not as the idea of
connectedness, but as the real reciprocal
opening between you and another person.
They disclose to you in a way that allows
you to disclose to them, and you're mutually
affording that.
And that goes from being something that you
just think to something that you found yourself
deeply being shaped by as you participate
in it.
Tim Ferriss: I'm glad I asked, and I hope
to ask — Well, I am going to ask many more.
We've got plenty of time.
This is fun.
I wanted to come back to something you mentioned,
and that is, I'm going to paraphrase here
because I can't recall the exact wording that
you used.
But effectively, some interwoven fabric that
is more fundamental than the subjective-objective
dichotomy that we use.
I'm curious if that is an older way of knowing
if that is — it's a revisiting of an older
way of knowing or relating to reality, or
if that is a newer way of thinking about something
that could connect and underlie those types
of concepts.
I'm asking in part because I had a conversation
a few weeks ago with Wade Davis, who's an
ethnographer, and —
John Vervaeke: Yeah, I've read one of his
books.
Tim Ferriss: And he's written quite a bit
about different ways of knowing, which I certainly
want to dive into with you as well.
Is what you referred to — something old,
is it something new?
Is it something that has no temporal fixed
point?
John Vervaeke: Well, I mean, the answer is
both.
That's not as a cop-out Canadian answer.
What I mean by that is there's definitely
important providence, and I'll talk about
it in a sec.
But I'm not recommending that we simply think
we can return to that in some sort of a historical
manner.
So that's what I mean when I'm sort of caveating.
This notion that our relationship to reality
is more about this connectedness, this is
obviously in the whole Neoplatonic tradition,
this idea of participation that — one way
the ancients thought about it is, well, this
has a structural functional organization to
it that allows it to act the way it does.
Who best knows this?
Somebody who could describe it?
Or somebody —
Tim Ferriss: For people who have audio only,
this, you're pointing at the water bottle.
John Vervaeke: Oh, sorry.
Yeah, sorry, everybody.
Thanks for that.
Now, who actually knows this better?
Somebody who could describe it or somebody
who could make it?
Well, generally people say, well, somebody
who could actually make it, who actually bring
about the structural functional organization.
What does the maker have in their head?
Well, they have the structural functional
organization and they just have to put it
into that.
The thing that makes this act the way it does
is identical to something in your mind, and
you're both sharing in that.
This is called a contact epistemology.
You're actually in — that you're mutually
participating.
And so the relatedness and the connectedness
is more primordial.
That's sort of an idea running through the
whole Neoplatonic tradition, which I would
argue following Arthur Versluis is really
the spiritual grammar of the west is the Neoplatonic
tradition.
In that sense, it's old.
In another sense, it's very new because what's
coming out of 4E cognitive science is exactly
this kind of thing.
This has to do with ways of knowing.
I talk about, because of the work I do in
4E cogsci, four kinds of knowing, and maybe
we can get into that.
But the point is that three of those four
kinds of knowing are about this kind of connectedness
and mutual participation.
And so I find this very interesting, the sort
of cutting edge cogsci is arguing that this
is a better way of — even to use the metaphor,
your mind is not in your head.
It's between your embodied brain and the world.
That's where the mind is, and that's how you
should think of the mind.
That's really cutting edge and important,
and there's a lot of important work being
done about it.
But in a lot of ways it hearkens back to that
ancient Neoplatonic tradition.
It's both old and new in really, really persuasive
ways, I would say.